i can't stop farting recently it's
terrible the most unpleasant [ __ ]
like five minutes ago are we rolling
i swear it's not a trash taste recording
damn les gaunt takes like a wicked [ __ ]
like i know we're about to start
recording when god comes out of his like
[ __ ] training arc oh wow just it's just
on schedule you know like
all
right
welcome to this episode of trash taste
i'm your host of course your boy connor
with mike wazowski here i seen you back
mike and
i like how you grab the g fuel though
just i didn't want to hurt mike like
by the way mike my my i might i can't
handle mike that harshly
it's great seeing you back mike and of
course the the boys i guess
we're second to mike of course we're all
second to mike joey
he's the real player mike wazowski for
you all your listeners out there
people are like oh there's a guess
called mike i forget very quiet i forget
sometimes that we have audio only
listeners which
shout out to you guys hello i'm waving
at you right now even though you can't
see
let us know your presence oh wait you
can't audio
so what do you always been up to
recently i mean this is the first
recording session of
the new year for us right yeah oh yeah
it is yeah yeah so
we just come out of our christmas and
new year's i guess
quote-unquote break yeah because it
didn't really feel like a break even
though it's never really a christmas
holiday for youtubers because i feel
like
we we've talked about this many times
before but we never we are very bad at
taking breaks
if anything it's like the last minute
grind right yeah we do at the end of the
year
i mean i've just been watching a [ __ ]
ton of anime because it's the end of the
year
this is like my one time of the year
where i actually just sit down and just
catch up
to the year because you don't feel bad
right because you know that everyone's
not like doing anything
yeah yeah i don't feel bad for like
bingeing a few shows right exactly
what did you binge gone what did you
watch basically
most of everything i missed in 2020 so i
watched uh jiu-jitsu tyson
yes that was so good have you watched
that yet no bro it's so
good i don't want you anymore
it's really [ __ ] good like i was
going into it thinking like are we just
going to get like
ever like every year there's everyone's
like dude this is the shonen yeah it's
going to replace that
that's that's what i've just been
hearing then i'm just like they said
that about doctor stone they said that
about a lot of shows last couple years
and i'm just like all right juicy
kissing is where i've actually got like
a job watching it like i'm actually yeah
i'm actually like hyped like it's
something it's it's a show
that is just it just knows what it's
doing and it's obviously been like
influenced from previous shonen but
my god it's just doing everything that
he needs to do right
all i've heard is that if you watch the
anime it basically
does everything the manga does so it
just makes the manga obsolete
great yeah i mean that's that was just
that was just demon slayer right yeah
yeah yeah
i want i want no manga get rid of manga
i'm sick and tired of these
kids i was like this man's done like
entire manga reading streams before
because i'm about ready to throw hands
right now
exactly i'm tired of manga readers
constantly playing the same damn card
right
when is that card gonna get old how many
times can you use the i've read the
manga
oh i use it all the [ __ ] times how
many times can you use it before you're
just an [ __ ]
i just and i think a lot of margaritas
just don't care
i mean so everyone just says the jiu
jitsu anime is exactly
basically what i've heard is that the
anime does everything the manga does but
better
yeah i mean from what i understand
that's just a lot of showing seems to be
the
you know and attack on titan's doing it
yeah like i don't understand why there
was even a thing of
let's just let's just change the story
unless that you know haven't been
adapted yet
which like had been sorry finished yep
sorry um why why
even change the story in my mind
whenever everyone loved this thing so
everyone's like yeah everyone loves this
show
let's just change it i mean i feel like
you've started watching anime after the
period where
there was like so many anime adaptations
that just [ __ ] around
with the manga and the story that you've
forgotten that this was a legitimate
like selling point where we had a manga
that followed
i mean we had an anime that followed the
manga through to the yeah i understand
why they did it probably like i'm
[ __ ] sh they're in the 90s or 80s
right yeah
what's 90s and jump adaptations right
where it's just like oh no
i like this manga i imagine the
producers were just like i'm sick and
[ __ ] tired of these manga readers on
their high horse you know what i'ma [ __ ]
them over and make something they can't
say oh i know what happens yeah that's
probably why because they probably like
brought the manga readers to the
screenings they were like yeah yeah
you know what it's going do you know if
anything no if anything it made the
mongeria look better because then the
anime watchers would be like well i've
heard from the manga readers that this
anime is pretty good
and then they go and they're like so
what happens in the manga
could you tell us could you tell us
we're we really want to we're interested
now finally
no but dude do you find that like the
older you get the less anime
like the less anime that you watch but
the more manga that you read yeah i mean
right now i feel like that's like the
path of every anime fan
maybe i'm not old enough yet i don't
know i haven't got that yeah i think
you're like what two years younger
exactly let's go like it's 25.
it was around your age where i was like
manga's a thing really
yeah 24 yeah which you didn't start
reading manga properly like
i've been reading all my life but the
thing is like up until around like a
couple of years ago
i would be like very heavily like i'd
say like 80 20
anime manga but now it's like kind of
flipped around i'm like 80 20 manga to
anime now because
you just realized that reading manga is
basically watching anime but just more
optimized yeah it's basically the speed
run version of watching anime right
basically no voice acting no music do
this [ __ ] myself
the only the only part where it could
like potentially [ __ ] up is like on the
author right there's like no
second hand to be like because it's just
like it's just like pure story right you
know you don't need
you don't need anything else but just
the pure story and sometimes there's
only one person to blame if it sucks
that's because it's like you don't know
what you're missing out because you
never think about it like
yeah we you would never i'll keep coming
back to it you don't know that you
needed jono's theme in your life
until you had jordan's theme in your
life right like part five was amazing
without jordan's theme i mean
but now part five has jordan yeah yeah
but like ten times didn't you read the
manga of part five before you watched
it and i think the anime is better yeah
yeah no no we're gonna agree with this
okay we all agree with it yeah i was
like wait i was giving it a second to
sit there i'm like all right i'm waiting
for the fans no no no no no
like i like of jojo's by the way i
haven't seen all of part five yet
but the little that i have seen is like
already better than the manga but not to
say but that's not to say that the hmong
is bad
this is a very rare case where i feel
like a legendary manga
has been adapted into a legendary
animation yeah
we don't get many of those i think it's
always one of the other right
because the problem is when you have a
legendary manga everyone's expectations
is so
[ __ ] high and i think that's what's
happening with the attack on titan right
now because i swear to god
everyone is looking for every little
[ __ ] nitpick they can think of
to [ __ ] on like the like the change of
studios right yeah
well i think map is doing a great
[ __ ] job right now and
the amount of like shitty takes i've
seen on twitter when the first episode
aired
i i was streaming the day after it came
out yeah all the comments were like what
do you think of the
the 3d cgi connor and attack on titan i
was like i don't even [ __ ] notice it
what do you mean
yeah it looked gross what do you mean
i'm like it was like two seconds and it
looked fine
stop [ __ ] nitpicking i love no i love
all those shitty takes where it's like
oh it's done but
knowing now that it's done by mapper
instead of uh uh
was it silvery no not simple studio with
knowing that it's done by mapper instead
of studio it just it just feels
different
i just i just feels different yeah i had
this image of my head of someone in
their house right they've got like
shingeki no kyojin [ __ ] all over the
room yeah waiting with that popcorn like
yes the moment like the cgi comes on
like
oh [ __ ] this
i knew they'd [ __ ] it up no because what
i want to know is that did they just
forget
what the colossal titans looked like in
season two with the three
it looked like absolute garbage compared
to the cg now and just because every
titan cg now
people like i don't know it's it's just
bad takes
and i feel like it's just because it's
such a
massively popular franchise that i feel
the
new like map doing a great job and you
got a great story anyway
that's that's what i love about
following like those like massive toxic
fan bases right it's just
the amount of [ __ ] takes that come out
of it it's just so entertaining
and people like [ __ ] on the opening
as well and i'm like what was wrong with
the opening
that's what people said about the last
opening and now everyone [ __ ] loves
the last opening
i already get it man people just get
angry every every [ __ ] season but i
guess it's because
the problem is is that someone has a bad
take on twitter and then everyone
[ __ ] clowns on them so
yeah that's the only take that anyone
sees everyone's [ __ ] clowning on that
guy who's like the opening sucks
was all colorful although to be fair the
attack on titan like when episode one
came out there was
a lot of [ __ ] dates yeah it was just all
over my timeline i'm like who
who are these because people want
brownie points man and so if you're
running for one looking like a clown
well that's the thing right because to
these people it's like people aren't
going to see if you're a clown
but if you if you that one time you get
a successful take
that like takes off yeah imagine the
clout you get just yes it's it's it's
like the hot the science behind hot
takes right
because hot takes aren't actually hot
takes it's like saying unpopular
opinions
right the unpopular opinions that people
upvote aren't actually unpopular
opinions
you know it's it's just it's like people
say unpopular
opinions just so they can get brownie
points because it's never actually
if it's an actual unpopular opinion
that's the opinion that people [ __ ] on
you know what i mean you're like
that that statement alone just like
completely negated my let's fight
seriously
because that's what that show is all
about taking unpopular opinions
yeah i love i love that but like that
that's why i have such
trouble with like making a next episode
of that because every time i'm like hey
guys give me your unpopular opinions on
anime
the top replies are like i think cabbage
pocono pico is bad
i'm like really you know [ __ ] same
right yeah i remember like because i
there's like voice actors do a lot of
those challenges on twitter they're like
hey man like
what's an unpopular voice acting opinion
and it was like you know
uh i think hard work matters the most
and stuff like that it's like what do
you mean
that isn't what what's even an opinion
that's genuinely good advice
like just do the thing like what's
unpopular about it
that's like the level of like yeah i
don't know about it
it's what happens weird man especially
when you're in like communities on
twitter that's like creative stuff
yeah because i i love watching uh
artists twitter is my favorite
how they artist twitter is like watching
trash tv
to me it's it's like you can just grab
out you can just grab the popcorn and
it's like watching night to day fiance
or something you know
it's like the amount the amount of tea
that is built
on like artist twitter like it's it's
it's more tea than the [ __ ] americans
threw into the water when like they
gained independence man my [ __ ]
i don't know why but it's why is it
almost always written in lowercase
it's like it's like never it it's never
proper punctuation
they're just like let's just make it as
lowercase as possible [ __ ] seven
seven tweet thread and it's just like
it's just [ __ ] that you could have
summed up into just one tweet
yeah there's a lot of funny ones i love
it as well when it's like
people just artists are like um giving
advice to each other and they're just
like they all like repeat the same stuff
and it's always interesting sometimes
because they'll be like
yeah you should charge people for your
art and i'm like is this like
not known like i should charge people
for work like what somehow this is like
well apparently it's pretty pop like
it's pretty common that i mean you see
the messages on like for exposure right
yeah
that's her account where for exposures
twitter account people like ask people
to do things
for exposure yeah which is very funny
and is that an unpopular opinion you
just came
doing well honestly yeah that artist
should get paid i'm going to do an
unpopular take right now
guys guys don't don't don't count me for
this but uh
this honor should get paid for that
to be fair though i joke on that but a
lot of voice actors like when they start
out they'll get like they'll they'll
spend all their money on like the new
stuff
and then they'll be like yeah yeah i'll
do your commercial for free
because people because it's it's
different with artists and i think voice
actors because voice actors like you get
credits
right yeah you need credits yeah so it's
like a race everyone's just like
devaluing themselves because they're
like
yeah i'll i'll do your your kellogg's
commercial for two dollars in a kitkat
bar
like that's fair that's good my name's
on the creditor right yeah yeah yeah
well i think that there is a balance
that should be taken because
there is value in clout basically i mean
that's that's that's how we make our
money right it's lit it's literally we
are monetizing clouds that is that is
the modern day
we are we are clout chasers as an
occupation but like this
no no but like i i i get you know
artists should definitely be paid and
you definitely have a skill set but
there's there's also building up your
personal branding as well which you have
to worry about
and that's the problem right is that so
many artists starting out they don't see
themselves as a brand
yeah exactly because of that honest
mentality right they're not like oh no
i'm just doing it because i like drawing
yeah i don't want to make this a
profession but then they make
they make one piece where it's really
popular and getting shared [ __ ]
everywhere and then suddenly they're
like
actually i'm a brand um you're stealing
yeah yeah because i've seen i've seen
the exact opposite of
like talented artists who just don't
know how to charge here where you have
like
an artist who has like two drawings on
their portfolio or something and are
charging like
ridiculous amounts of money and it's
just like come on there's
there is a balance that needs to be
taken here right or yeah my favorite is
when they like
i've worked with some artists before and
like great you know it's all good
um you know and it's it's all reasonable
all the prices seem fair and then i'm
like oh yeah it's like for like
commercial use or whatever and they're
like
oh oh you're like selling it and then
they might like they might try and
figure out like okay you make this much
money
it's now worth ten thousand dollars for
this piece yeah yeah
like what what do you what do you mean
what no what okay
but i'm pretty sure on your website it
said 20 dollars
looks of industry standard rates that
ain't right okay well ah
i'm not pepsi you know yeah yeah i don't
know which is basically the
fiverr environment right how how is it
like working with people
how do you like how do you know how much
you're worth and
it's how to sell yourself on friday
because i think on fiverr it's
inherently people like devalue
themselves but there are people on
fiverr who are charging like five
hundred dollars
yeah for like five dollars like for
honestly what is like really bad quality
yeah but then the thing is right on
fiverr at least
i can only speak with voice actors i've
had a lot of voice actors on driver and
like voice actors on fiverr
there's like five dollars is like you
get a very wide
variety of like skill yeah we you go all
the way from headset mike because
fiverr doesn't there's no checks there's
no there's no one on five being like
yeah you seem like a voice actor you're
good to go champ it's like oh you have
something that that your pc recognizes
as an audio recording device
you're good to go like because it's
tyler1 [ __ ] headsets
i've heard people with worse quality
microphones than tyler1 screaming
they're charging like 20 with commercial
rights as an option
and i'm like what you what commercial
how do you not know what like a good
microphone is but you know that you
should be charging for commercial rights
like
these two things are like come on like
but then fiverr does like scummy things
as well like fiverr takes
cuts from like the tips and fiverr also
like i i i don't like personally that
fiver makes charges extra for like
higher quality audio files i just think
you should just send a word file
right like or high quality so are people
just sending mp3s
unlike kilobytes [ __ ] putting the wav
behind jail or something
yeah they put like wav files behind pay
walls sometimes like why don't do that
just give me the [ __ ]
file why would you not do that that's
like different between high quality and
local it doesn't matter but
i didn't know [ __ ] the uh voice
acting industry had dlc now
jesus christ that's literally dlc the
land expansion
the ray tracing voice acting like you
gotta [ __ ] pay five dollars extra
but then there's like there's people on
fire who charge like you know who
charge industry rates and i don't think
fiverr given the like is
fiverr shouldn't be charging industry
rates in my opinion no because it's like
not really where
you should be hiring industries
shouldn't be hiring on five and the ones
that do i think should be kind of like
you know
we won't get into that yeah never had
that experience myself
but yeah no i mean it's it's it's
difficult and fiverr voice actors are
you just listen to that audio you'll
know if they're worth it yeah
it's not just five audios it's it's five
it's fiverr everything
everything every creative uh job you can
think of
because it's i the way i feel i feel
about fiverr is that it should be it's a
good testing ground
because you get a such a wide range and
i feel like it would be a good place to
build up your portfolio
because from what i yeah what what i see
like
it doesn't really matter where you had
your education or whatever
what we really care about because most
of the time we are the clients now we're
buying the service yeah
we just care about your portfolio that's
the thing that's most important yeah
exactly i might
show your work yeah it's a good place to
build up your portfolio as well
and also get paid yeah yeah because yeah
i mean i used to recommend to voice
actors you know if you
if no one's hiring you you don't know
where to start you know don't go to one
of these websites that cost like four
hundred dollars
a year to sign up to because you know
you're not gonna make your money back
yeah like for example if we're hiring
video video editors like we can get
emails about people who you know are
qualified for
x y and z but at the end of the day
we're most likely going to pick
people who have worked on anime anime
videos right because we know they have
experience working
in that [ __ ] field who like actually
know us and like
yeah yeah yeah our videos yeah yeah
exactly so it
that's that's the thing it's it's more
about knowing
your target audience and knowing what
your personal branding is and it's less
important
about what you put on your cv because we
we don't we don't really care about cvs
that much right i don't give a [ __ ] or
school you went to
is the [ __ ] good or not like that's all
there is to it there's lots of video
editors out there right it's just
it's just a matter of i know i normally
go to like fiverr somewhere for like if
i need something
like one off and like fast like i just
like because other times it's a bit of a
pain to search around
have you used fiverr other than in like
in your fiverr videos
yeah i've used it uh used it for uh
where did i use it
uh if i need something composed because
i don't know any composers
right like i'm making music i i go from
knowing zero composers to kevin penkin
i can't go oh kevin mate i got this
video idea because
she just composed me a trick like so
i'll go to someone i'm like i'm only
like
make like a midi track of this or make
like a version of this
it's normally very basic like thing
right yeah i'm like copy this thing
yeah um yeah i mean i think i've had
like some emotes on my twitch drawn
there
yeah a lot of twit there's a lot of
twitch stuff on there yeah well i mean
there's a lot of artists on fiverr right
yeah about this [ __ ] oh my god there's
so many yeah um or well
quite quite honestly is that is that
where you get your twitch stuff because
i've actually been looking to
try and like upgrade my twitch
presentation because my twitch
presentation is [ __ ] [ __ ] because
i've never given the [ __ ] about
streaming before
problem is on on fiverr it's tailored
towards like i think
what the like general audience of people
who are looking to get into live
streaming with once right
so it's all like very gamer looking
you know what i mean when i say that
right like like
90 of the fiverr stuff for like target
like twitch
and like twitch overlays all looks like
something that is an application to the
face clan
like it doesn't look like it's like the
default ones that you get on like
streamlabs yeah which is why i think i
ended up hiring someone
who i know that did a lot of this stuff
and who watched some of my stuff so they
were kind of familiar with
my i met an artist recently who
probably going to get to hire because
yeah it's the same thing as like
because right now i'm using like a
default one i'm just like i should
probably
probably personalize it a little more
yeah i want to stand out a little bit
how did you
how did you guys find artists do you
just dm people on twitter i just tweet
out or like ask on live streams i'm like
hey guys
i like need something can someone tell
me like where i go
a lot of them actually i find through
like them doing fan out of me
okay yeah so like the the uh the person
i'm probably going to be hiring soon as
rocket cat who did like a bunch of like
drawings with uh me and chris the
journey across japan and stuff
right it's really [ __ ] cute so i
asked her i was like yo can you do some
twitch stuff and she's like okay
yeah so just just asking around i have
like no idea what art is worth so
whatever they give me if it's not
ridiculous
yeah basically yeah yeah sure [ __ ] it
i'll pay that whatever man i'm way more
comfortable being like what do you want
yeah you know versus like i'll give you
15
always a debate right is it is it you as
the the buyer should ask
or should the person like the client say
hey this is what i'm worth right yeah
because i
frustrates me when i hear like what's
your budget and i'm like i don't have a
[ __ ] budget
what are you worth yeah like what do you
want what's your hourly rate you tell me
like i don't know
i understand that that's in place for
people who can't maybe afford yeah
a lot of things but i'm like i don't
know what whatever you think it's worth
tell me i'll pay it it's like it's like
a [ __ ] standoff right
you're like you're waiting for the first
one to like say a number it's just like
how much how much is this worth like
what's your budget i [ __ ] hate that
debate right
like i get it though from the artist's
perspective because like they're
probably like oh if i say
something that's a little too high then
i'm afraid i might lose the client
right even that's when you can negotiate
right you can be like i think that's a
little
a little too high was it maybe something
yeah but a lot of them starting off
don't know anybody that's true
i was afraid at first as well like when
you know i'd get sponsorship
opportunities they'd be like
what do you want for and i'm like uh
don't know
how much do you have have either you
been ever good at like
bartering or whatever i love doing it uh
like i've learned to do it just because
my dad was really good at it
right like i [ __ ] suck at it man like
this is why i love japan where
everything
is labeled and priced because whenever i
go to thailand
you just you just play this dance around
everything you buy man
because it's a it is a [ __ ] dance
where you're just like oh okay so you're
gonna you're gonna
you're gonna charge me that well i'm
gonna like say a price that's 10 times
lower
in australia it's like a dance that you
will only dance if you decide to enter
the ring
it's like you can stand back and just
kind of be like oh this is how much you
want all right and put your wallet out
but then you could also be like
hold on let me roll up my sleeves real
quick let's sound the baby come on
because like my dad was so [ __ ]
because my dad was has been like an i.t
salesman for like the past third years
so this man i don't know how the [ __ ] he
did but i remember like
when i was in like uh high school or
something
and i wanted to buy my first guitar
right like a proper electric guitar
and he bought me like this like really
nice epiphone guitar which is worth like
two grand or something yeah and he
looked at it and he's like
so this is just the guitar right and the
guy's like yeah he's like
can i have a chat with you mate and he
and he talks to the dude but like back
behind like the kind of into a room
right he's like hold on son i'm just
gonna
you [ __ ] beat him up i don't know why
in the back why could he do it at the
counter i don't know i don't know but he
like took him to the bag he's like all
right let me talk
and then i think i think maybe like 10
minutes later he came out
it's pretty it's free
he came out 10 minutes later and he's
like all right so the guitar now is 1500
and he threw in a free amp
and i'm like what did you say what did
you what did you do
how did you do he's like i just talked
to him mate i'm like no no no no
like if it was that easy then everyone
would be getting deals
it's not just a matter of oh i just
talked to him like what did you say to
him
everyone can tell more than that yeah
yeah yeah i was like i was like what did
you say
[ __ ] jedi mind trick was it like
that's that's technically yeah
did you like inception like plant the
seed he's just like it's 1500 now
the first time i ever saw like bartering
happen i was like my mind was blown
i was like wait you can go against the
price that's written yeah
you can do it as an option cause i was
in like we were on a school trip to
new york it was the first time our
school ever like went to a different
country
yeah and um i really wanted to go to new
york for school yeah dude it was chaos
it was pure [ __ ] holy [ __ ]
how old were you uh 16 i think oh my god
wow it was an absolute
mess bro [ __ ] the the only the only
school trips i went to was just like
france at most that was the first year
that i've ever gone to that was like the
booziest one and for some reason for one
year they never did it again i think
they realized it was a horrible mistake
yeah they took us to new york it was a
[ __ ] mess
it was awful it was like i mean if i was
a teacher that would have hated it yeah
i had a great time but yeah
it was i remember it was very expensive
but we stayed in like really [ __ ]
sketchy motels i can talk about it more
after the story but
we were we were basically like i really
wanted converse because obviously when
you're like 15 16 you see the [ __ ] on
like american tv you're like you're on
conversation
yeah so i went to a store and my friend
was with me and
he was only he was in the year above me
and i was like man i want to get these
but i've only got like 30 bucks left and
they're 40 bucks he was like oh
i'll ask him if we can do it for 30.
he's like 17. bartering with him and
then eventually
he he said i'll give you for 30 if you
give me a two dollar tip
and i'm like is that okay are you
allowed to do that i don't know if he's
the owner or what
but that's what he got it down to and i
was so impressed when i went home to the
uk i try to do it but immediately all
the stores are like
no wait what store was this i'd go to
like
in america or the uk in america it was
like a [ __ ]
official store i think it was like a
mall it was like an independent store
maybe i think that's why i got away with
it so i went to like a [ __ ]
supermarket in the uk
go to the thing go to [ __ ] tesla yeah
he's like
five pounds with a little too much for
this i'm sorry you you're you're you're
selling me this kellogg's [ __ ]
creams for like how much you know
it's a little three pounds a little
expensive yeah could you do 250. i'll do
250.
i'll give you 250. no
i'm like oh okay [ __ ] i know that i
never tried it again for a while
but i like going to places where you can
do it because i i like trying to do it
i don't often i don't i don't know how
like
i i probably could do it if i really
wanted to
but i'm always just so [ __ ] afraid to
do it as well because i don't know how
like um i don't know because with that
kind of stuff if you're not coming in
with confidence
you're basically [ __ ] right because
there's no way you're going to win it
you you need to come in with like a
winning mentality you've got to come in
with like the
biggest dick energy i'm like i can do it
it just takes so much [ __ ] energy but
whenever
you're in a place in like thailand
that's like 90 percent of the stores you
go to and you just want
a store where you pay the price that
they originally asked for
and just not have to like do this mini
game every time yeah
i i remember i watched like the there's
a i think i mentioned him on the
youtuber episode he has videos about
prague
and he covers like taxi scams i was in
prague yeah i had a taxi
yeah and i was like this is like in the
simulations this is exactly what he
spoke about because they were trying to
charge me what he said was being
overcharged
yeah i remember i was with my mate in
the taxi i'm like no i've seen the
youtube video i've got this that i'm
like i'm not paying that that's too much
and eventually we got like half the
price it was like wow you're supposed to
be like he shows like 50 euros for like
uh
the equivalent and check money for like
um
like it was supposed to be like half
that it was like only like a 20 minute
like 15 minute journey
where i was like no i've seen the
simulations i know this is right
and there's youtube channels of dudes
who go around india like bartering
oh yeah i can imagine
bartering in india is just like next
level that's like that's like
expert mode it's literally it looks like
a reality tv show with every purchase
the guy's like i'm walking away
i'm going i'm not getting in your taxi
and then i'm like [ __ ] following them
please please sir this episode is
sponsored by princess connect redive one
of the most successful
gacha games in japan since its release
which is now available worldwide on ios
and android while joey tells you all
about princess connect redive
me and god are gonna be eating onigiri
and we're gonna see who can eat the most
before joey finishes his ad read
although these are literally just blocks
of carbs uh so set your expectations low
so i'm going to be reading this
as slowly as you know so why
why did we agree to this all right joey
you may proceed to tell us about today's
sponsor you can please
please go let's introduce i'm just
kidding let's introduce you to the game
princess connect re-dive one of the
hottest and successful gacha games from
japan
princess connect redive was developed by
cy games the developer of shadowverse
dragalia lost and granblue fantasy shut
up gone i'm reading a script
so you can expect that this game is
amazing this all-inclusive anime rpg is
full of beautifully animated cutscenes
special abilities and characters
furthermore
it has such an incredible deep and
original story that there's even an
anime based off the game which was
released last year in 2020 with season
two on the way so look forward to that
there are over 50 heroines and counting
strengthen and ascend them to reach
their
potential every character in guild has
their own unique story to unlock
and is voiced by the most popular voice
actresses in the industry build your own
personal guild house fight for the top
ranks of multiple pvp modes
battle with your clan conquer dungeons
and plenty more with plenty of events
cross-brand collaborations and new
content to keep players engaged and you
know what just like gone and conor
there'll be plenty of rice balls
during your journey as well we're not
just doing this because it's like a
weird thing this is
not even hungry so make sure to click
the links down in the description below
to get the game for yourself and thank
you to princess connect redev once again
for sponsoring
this video on time i won hey got one
it tastes so boring show your plate wait
what you had two
no you didn't there's some foul play
going on here
did you get a princess connect reader
sponsoring this episode back to the
video good connor get good
but yeah back to my my school trip to
america that's my first time ever going
to america
right and uh i remember those two things
i was really excited for going to
america where do you think they were
in and out no they can go there i only
went to new
new york the food i wanted two things
from what i'd seen from media i wanted
twinkies and
i wanted mountain dew and wait did they
not have mountain dew in
uk they do but it's not like it's the
stuff without like the green stuff in it
because that that stuff's illegal in the
uk so our mountain is our mountain dew
just tastes like sprite
what yeah we have it but it's not that
popular and it doesn't taste like
mountain dew at all it's really not
proper mountain dew wait
what the [ __ ] is in mountain dew that
makes it illegal in the uk the stuff
that makes it super green
really yeah yeah i'm like because i'm
pretty sure like all the sodas in the uk
you're not allowed to use corn syrup
either
so like like coke and soda in america
taste different from
like sodas in the uk right right in fact
i almost does have less sugar in it
yeah it has it has like a little less
sugar and you can taste it you can
definitely taste oh yeah
i mean the first time i had like proper
mountain dew well i guess now i know
it's proper mountain dew in america i
was like
i'll show you might have different it
might not but twinkies twinkies are [ __ ]
junkies taste like ass why did you think
it was good because in all the tv shows
they made twinkies look
amazing yeah and i'm like from what tv
show like zombieland or something
actually because he's obsessed with them
in zombieland
oh yeah that was that then i also
learned from that they were like can
survive nukes or something i don't think
that's i don't i don't think that's true
at all but in family guy
i wonder how much twinkies paid
zombieland like
that was fantastic advertising yeah that
was like five head advertising
i went there as a teenager and i [ __ ]
wanted this shitty
spongy thing that you put into your
mouth survival foods yeah
during an ad during apocalypse my god so
like i i'm prone to getting like
nosebleeds as well
until i got my nose cauterized all right
which is like when you like [ __ ] burn
it yeah yeah
um so i was getting i used to in if it
got like even remotely hot i would get
nosebleeds
really so when i went to america it was
just too hot it was in the summer and i
reached every day i had nosebleeds how
hot does it get in new york in the
summer it's pretty damn pretty
yeah i remember i went to new york once
in the summer and it was like pretty hot
and humid
ah it's like in the 30s i don't know why
i thought because this was so cold in
the winter i would assume it
got like quite cool in the summer it was
great though because any of the like
really boring places i would just be
like
come on and then just i'd get to go get
ice cream or something
the staff would go take me out because
we were like going through like a one
museum that was really [ __ ] boring i
can't know what it was as a kid because
oh it's the big
museum in new york now the smithsonian
was pretty cool because that was like
loads of exhibits and stuff but there
was some other museum they took us to
which was like maybe it was like the
some cia thing that was like books and i
was like i have no interest in this i
but i remember i have no interest they
just like
let us go around times square on our own
right
wow really yeah that could have gone
horrendously yeah
that sounds really dangerous like i'm
like time squared like i'm not i would
i wouldn't let my 16 year old i don't
feel safe i don't even feel safe during
the day in times square little on a
night
i don't feel safe as an adult there let
alone
like a 16 year old kid yeah and i
remember
this is so funny one of the kids came
back right i need a bunch of cds
and we were like why do you have cds and
he's like oh well uh the guys kept
coming up to me
and telling me if i wanted to hear them
spit so i kept having to buy them for
five dollars
and i was like you know the dudes come
up to you like yo he's my mixtape
yeah yeah yeah he was paying every time
for everyone that came
up to him so it's just all these like
shitty mixtapes
because i i can't remember what i did i
think i just went around all the stores
she looked at it and be like wow that's
so strange it would go in like eminem
world and be like
wow i can't afford any of this because
it would be like ten dollars for a pack
of m
m's yeah like wow i'm really broke huh
my parents really didn't
even afford m ms no no as well
our hotel right they put us in like i
think it's like the sun
in what is that called it's like the
comfort inn or something that's what
it's called
it's got like a sun logo yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah and i
remember we were all
baffled because the only thing they had
for breakfast was like burgers
that could be microwaved and it was
disgusting
and we were all like yeah american food
we ate it with like ah american food
it's like some white castle [ __ ] yeah it
was gross um i remember as well that uh
we had to get the bus everywhere and it
was just the worst because they tried to
fit
like they they use public buses like
private coaches
the more i'm the more you talking the
more i'm realizing why who decided to go
on a school trip
i think it was what must been one
teacher that really [ __ ] wanted me to
say
it makes sense that they didn't do it
the year after so we would go on like
the public buses like
the whole like 40 kids would go on a
normal public bus it was already full
that sounds terrifying yeah and then all
the all the dudes were like topless on
the bus and we were like oh god oh god
i'm in danger and then when the teachers
would all go to bed
all the [ __ ] kids just went out at
night and we were in
because because we were obviously we
were like not a rich school at all so we
were in like a really sketchy part of
new york yeah but you're rich enough to
go to new york though
not really it was i remember the whole
trip for like four or five days with
flights and five hotels
was like 800 pounds and everything was
taken for like
so it was i guess very budget very
budget
so the hotels we stayed in were like not
good at all we were
like in the ghetto bro they were like
hello imagine it you got like 40
just like white school kids that have no
idea what's going on
that they break out at night and they're
in like a ghetto and it's like yeah oh
god
you guys are like harlem or something i
can't remember where we were but we were
very far away it was like a 40-minute
bus
journey into town that could have been
anywhere yeah i think we were
like queens i think we might have been
around somewhere like that it was
definitely i remember that i remember
having these
because you would see on the movies that
new york was like yeah man it's bustling
it's great
yeah and i was like why is where we're
staying everything is boarded up
and dirty what's up with that why don't
we because the hustling bustling is like
two blocks yeah because i distinctly
remember
i really didn't like new york and i
liked dc because when we went to dc it
was really nice
and i remember that because i was just
scared when we were in new york
that was that was my first impression
going to new york as well because i i
also went when i
was a bit older so i was like 22.
i felt like when you're 16 and 22 the
way you see the world is completely
different yeah i don't know i i still
had this like you know the the the
american film image of new york yeah and
i was i remember my first time going
there i remember thinking man there's a
lot of street corners that i've never
seen in any films that uh
look pretty [ __ ] dodgy this is where
like spider-man's parents got killed
that's the thing when i went to new york
like four or five years ago like
it was really good if as long as your
neck was like above
like landscape right yeah it's like wow
these buildings look really good the
moment you look down just like
oh that's a lot of trash yeah because
that there is that that was my first
impression there is
a lot of trash that just has no has
never appeared on it like there is a
mountain of trash on this corner that is
like
reaching like traffic lights like my god
going to chinatown for the first time
it's
it don't hit there for this smell
differently
this is this episode 33 where we clown
on america
i remember actually i remember the
stream yesterday i had a person coming
being like
why do you guys hate america we don't
hate america yeah
i love how absurd america the the way
the way i talk about americans is like
the way i like
like to [ __ ] on my cousins you know what
i mean it's it's like the distant cousin
that i just like to talk [ __ ] about we
don't hate on america we just like
making fun of america
there's a big difference it's because
you know europe europe's boring there's
nothing weird about it america
is weird that's why i love it yeah no i
it comes from a place of love you know
what i mean
this is how us brits show like well you
know we talked [ __ ] to our like mates
yeah
yeah yeah that's how i see it yeah
they're like in it oh your teeth are
[ __ ] what go and drink some tea like
wait why are you making fun of america
all your mates [ __ ] and you call [ __ ]
mate that's how it works
true true would you ever live in america
have i asked this before
on the podcast i don't think you've
asked me on the podcast i think i've
asked you personally yeah yeah
what your answer was that's what i'm
asking i mean like i've given it
well you're dating oh yeah you're both
yeah yeah with americans
yeah we hate americans we hate america
we hate americans so much so that our
significant other is from that kind of
our americans the way sydney talks me
about food sometimes with like a
nostalgia i'm like disgusting
gosh i've i've considered living in
america for maybe like
a year just like give it a go like it's
an asylum
i would go there to visit you know yeah
like for real like i don't i don't hate
visiting like i love visiting america
but i don't i don't like i don't know
just difference in personality at least
with me and like way of living is like
it's
very different to what i mean i love how
open everyone is i i
do love how open everything is open
everyone is i feel like the biggest
thing i would have to get to
is like i like feeling safe
like the only thing stopping me from
living in america is the fact that even
during the day i don't feel safe
yeah like it's it's so weird for me
where you can be in some of the most
famous places
in the world in america and you just
can't walk anywhere i like
i like walking to places you know what i
mean it's all about like i feel like i
have to recalibrate my brain
in order to go like in in order to
travel to places in america because i
forget that you have to just drive
everywhere
walking isn't normalized because you
could you know it's it's just not safe
like even when you're in like the middle
of la right like you'd be like oh you
know i'll just like go to the starbucks
that's just around the corner you know
it's like
just going to the next town in an rpg
and that yet on the street corner
there's a level 100 crackers
i mean they're standing there being like
they're going to come past me when i was
in
san francisco man i felt like just
walking back to my hotel at 2am felt
like a cyberpunk mission dude
like the yeah music was playing in my
ears the fact that you said you walked
back
at 2am like already scares me yeah
okay i legit have never been scheduled
walking somewhere yeah right i was in
right in the middle of like the
financial district yeah
i was like [ __ ] i think i've mentioned
this before on the podcast as well but
yeah that was [ __ ] scary
i [ __ ] scared i'm just thinking about
it that's the only thing that's stopping
me from living in america
also everyone i know from san francisco
has had their car broken into
i've heard so many weird stories about
like some of the stories that maelynn
says because mainland is on south is
from san francisco yeah
where it's one of it's like it it's so
counterintuitive for me
where this is the place where it's got
like one of like the highest cost of
living pay like a million dollars a year
like a millionaire is considered like
poor there you know what i mean that's
that's kind of that's kind of the place
we're talking about yet it's a place
where
the cost of living is so high yet it
seems like
you still need to worry about some of
the stuff where i feel like if i'm
earning a million dollars i wouldn't
need to worry about it like
if i why would i need to worry like why
would i need to pay this much
and worry about living in a neighborhood
where my car could get broken into yeah
it feels like everyone who i've met from
san fran
has had something stolen they talk about
something wrong
they talk about that as if they got like
a parking ticket you know it's like oh
[ __ ]
got it again oh well yeah when melin was
talking about how she has to have like
one headphone in
just in case there's someone behind her
to like take her purse or something i'm
like
what the what the [ __ ] like why would
you how do you feel safe living in a
city like that or a country like that
for that matter this is why i'm
convinced the
cyber trucks being made it's purely so
it can withstand criminals in san
francisco or breaking in yeah right
everyone's going to be in like [ __ ]
like
armored trucks in san francisco but
they'll still find a way to break into
it
right but that's the thing the only
places i feel safe in america are like
the super tourist heavy places right
yeah so like the peers in san francisco
or like
you know [ __ ] vegas strip right yeah
uk somewhere in the middle i think like
you can't really like leave your laptop
on the dashboard
really no um i would argue though that's
like other than japan there's not a lot
of countries
no no no but like in the uk i'd leave
like my my headphones on the chair
i don't really mind risking that i'm
like whatever nah i wouldn't even do
that
what pencil you are london no other like
whales yeah it's whatever
well yeah because that's countryside
right what are they gonna do run away
with the sheep like whatever get off the
sheep
go go go go yeah i don't know i mean
it's
yeah i don't know it's weird i i really
want to i've always said this i've
always wanted to live for
in america for a year i would like to
live in america for i wouldn't mind
trying it out yeah i think if i move
from japan i think i would like to try
and get
i i i'm still like because me and cindy
want to move to america for a bit
because like her family's there and you
know she wants to be close to her family
for a while
it's just finding the perfect place that
i would actually want to live in
yeah i don't know where i could see
myself settling down in a minute because
like you know for youtubers it's like
the number one spot is always la
but [ __ ] living in l.a sorry if you're
from l.a
i heard this no it's not about it's
about la youtubers man it's oh yeah yeah
youtubers are a different beast man
they're they're they they are a
different breed
every every like there's i feel like
there's literally just two scenes on
youtube
youtube and laughs youtube like it's
totally different like i
i like and you know when someone's
living in l.a i swear because when you
talk to them you're like
bro you're just like in another reality
yeah you play by different you sound
brainwashed
but i get it because like that when
you're there like you feel it you feel
like you're in a different place yeah
when you're in l.a and you feel like
everything you do somehow has a bigger
weight to it i think i think that's what
they they think yeah everything's like
brand
new [ __ ] mic we were talking about
cloud chasing before la
croix la's like the epicenter of clout
chasing all right i feel like
everyone's out to get some clout yeah i
feel dirty when i'm there like yeah when
i'm talking to people
i'm just like dude i'm just i'm just
like i'm just like trying to get just a
starbucks for like
why are we talking about how many subs
you have like i don't care did you see
like that donkey video where
he like did a commentary over what was
he used to be a youtuber yeah but yeah
he he started one right so he has his
own little you want to go tell the rest
of it yeah so he
he basically commentates over like this
house tour and
it's it it is like when when when you
what the way donkey commentates it it is
basically like you're going into a
different [ __ ] world
because what was like the room like the
[ __ ] tortinos
training room or something i'm just like
this sounds like a like you say that out
of context and this sounds like a
dystopia
every room is a sponsor in the building
so when you mention
i'm in this room you have to say like
i'm in the the monster energy gaming
room
i can't i i want that for trash taste i
mean
and this is our del taco's toilet
i'm in the tenga recording dude
we should probably explain what a tanger
is to the audience i guess oh yeah
because youtube just recently got one
right
we've got a joke gift from a friend of
ours who gave us a tangle which is just
when i see them they make me look
uncomfortable like
sorry when i see them i feel
uncomfortable like i see it i'm like
why does it look like that why is it why
does it look like donkey kong's lips
it's [ __ ] disgusting what is that
it's so gross
i've never heard anyone refer to a
tangos donkey kong
no no no no no the stereotypical
oh oh yeah did anyone want to stick
their dick in here yeah yeah
it's disgusting yeah that's true how
horny you got to be yeah do that
yeah you know what i don't know because
because the thing is you know no one's
using like a fleshlight and an owner and
they're actually looking at it
like looking at it to be like oh yeah
i'm like basically [ __ ] a [ __ ] now
you know what i mean
like nobody cares what it looks like
it's so gross
i don't know i don't know how tango
managed to make it look normal
no they make it look like a like a like
an ornament yeah like a sleek thing
yeah i don't know you should if you come
to japan go check it out they're in like
donkey hotel like a lot of stores
yeah so there's like different types of
tenga there's like i remember the first
time i heard of it was just the tenga
eggs which
oh yeah yeah yeah which i
so yeah it's they they sell actual egg
cartons and there's these tender eggs
which are actually like i've never used
one before where do you put your dick in
there
so what does it work so you have to like
crack it open
and then it kind of stretches out so
it's basically it's basically just like
so
where you literally just crack it open
on the side yeah you kind of just
[ __ ] do this and it cracks on the
side and then
basically like the the the flesh like
part is kind of like squashed in so you
like stretch it out
right and then you kind of just wrap it
up don't ask me how i know that
you know what's one thing i've never
understood people who jack off into
socks
what's up with that yeah that's the
thing
i don't know anyone who jacks off in a
sock i thought i hear it all the time
i thought that was just an urban legend
there was someone in my university who
did it he would jack up
he had socks specifically for jackie why
would you give you a dick carpet bone
like that
like like how is that [ __ ]
comfortable for some reason
the thought of using tissue is too much
effort or getting into it it's like
rubbing your bare dick on the carpet
yeah
it's like it just sounds like it hurts
is that how furries happen
is that that's the first step
that's how you that's how you get it you
get a taste for the fur yeah yeah yeah
oh my god you can't go back because but
you hear it all the time right it's like
the whole like oh
crusty socks kind of thing i'm just like
haha that's a funny fictional thing that
never happened and yeah so the guy in my
one he would use them like he would use
his dirty socks that he could you know
when you go to bed you take off your
socks right yeah
so he would just throw them in his room
then when he was going to do it he would
grab one
and then he's like well it doesn't
matter i'm gonna wash it anyway i'm like
so wait you're telling me
you're telling me let me get this
straight you might have played like
rugby you might have gone running
you would use that song and then he
literally gave himself uh his own
football
foot he gave himself a self-foot job
basically
i'm so sorry to the listeners who are
grossed out by this yeah but i just
couldn't believe it and i
i was i've asked people like do you do
this this is a thing that you do know
anyone and like yeah
i know people who know people who do it
i'm like why are you friends with them
what's wrong with you yeah but what if
they're doing like uh oh yeah a friend
of a friend of mine i've heard
but it's actually i have heard people
who have found out like their brothers
or like the sister found their brother
doing it i've heard that oh that's the
worst
yeah that's gross are you walking in
your brother you see us like socks why
are they crusty oh my god i just don't
understand how they because people
i've heard of people as well using the
same sock more than once without
cleaning it
what yeah do they want to get like a
[ __ ] uti
i think yeah that's what that's what is
this like the speed run any percent to
like a sexual transmitter yeah
it's like i don't understand any percent
this is like a victorian era syphilis
simulator like what is this
at which point was a tissue just too
like
complicated to figure out get a box they
they're not hard to put on any service
they're flat you know just
or if you can't even do that just roll
the toilet paper you know like that will
also suffice
i don't understand yeah i mean like dude
aside from like [ __ ] apparently
wanking into socks
which which is what we're talking about
now do you actually know anyone who owns
like a [ __ ] pocket [ __ ] or
like like a non-tanker yeah like a
non-tanker i feel like people don't
admit it i feel like i feel like there's
probably way more than i realized i
don't know
anyone who's per like because they're
not telling you guys they're not telling
you
is it just is it just a thing that guys
just don't tell each other
or is it just a thing that guys just
don't buy i don't know i think there's a
certain
shame in admitting that you come into a
plastic toy yeah
i feel as well like maybe we're just
hanging out with like
not those kinds of people yeah you know
what i mean i think it's also because
like
like you said they look [ __ ] ugly and
they look [ __ ] weird like
there's no there's no way that your mom
opens a drawer and see
sees sees like an owner hole or like a
pocket [ __ ] you explain that [ __ ] away
i like to me in my mind it has to be
like there's two graphs right there's
effort to clean it yeah and enjoyment i
get out of it
all right and i if it takes you like min
maxing pocket [ __ ]
because the problem is right is that i
don't want to clean it i don't want
anything to do with it
yeah i want it to be done like and
dusted yeah yeah you get it in a tissue
you throw that [ __ ] away
yeah right it's gone it's out of my mind
like do i really
worst case scenario if i'm really
desperate for lube for some reason i'm
sure i can just lube up my hand right
but i don't want to make a mess
i'm that is like my priority here i just
want to get this over with i'm not
trying to have like i'm not lighting
candles you know scenting the air like i
don't give a [ __ ] i'm just trying to get
it done
turn on the moonlight like
i don't understand like who like it's
that enjoyable to them that they're
willing to go then to the kitchen have
this shameful thing and just like i'm
gonna clean out my jizz
i don't wanna touch that i don't wanna i
don't wanna [ __ ] do anything with it
i get disgusted when i get a little bit
on my hand i'm like
oh no that won't do at all get that off
some people just just don't care man
it's just it's just weird for me because
like it seems like it's you know
socially acceptable for girls to have
like whatever sex toy they want right
and i mean you go to i mean they sell it
on high street stores like in england we
have ann summers where you can just go
in there and
i get it it's yeah for a guy it's like
you can do it in like two seconds right
get it down
if you really need to right yeah for a
girl i guess i think it's longer right
it's a bit harder for the girl you
actually have to like
light the cameras and turn on the mood
lights right yeah but i also imagine
like fingering yourself is probably
i wouldn't know it's probably a little
more difficult
i don't know i want to know that the
thumb is way harder than the pinky no no
i wouldn't
[Music]
i'm guessing we're
my stool broke one time never been the
same
[Laughter]
yeah i guess like i'm in japan i am
impressed by the [ __ ] variety
of sex toys i mean i i i see it way more
often because
you know i'm [ __ ] dating sydney and
it's her [ __ ] job to review these
different types of things
but man they they are so imaginative
and i'm i i unironically like love going
to
just [ __ ] like there's one in
akihabara that i always go to called
love mercy
i think it's called yeah it's like under
the bridge and it's like a four-story
[ __ ] sex shop
oh yeah and that's right in the middle
of akihabara right in front of them
it doesn't look like a adult store yeah
and like the fourth floor like the top
floor is like no females allowed because
like that's where all of like the guy
toys and like the
the [ __ ] up porn is and i was like how
bad could it be so i went up there i was
like
yeah i mean i'm allowed on this floor
technically under the rules of the store
but i i don't know
i don't want to be on this floor it
feels illegal just being
there man seeing when you get when you
go i feel like i'm committing a felony
yeah when you get up higher and then you
see the sex dolls the actual like things
and they're [ __ ] expensive too
there's like 10 grand right yeah yeah
like the good quality ones i'm like
what's the difference i don't
the like the thought of having to clean
out
like a fake person what is the
maintenance cost on these [ __ ] dolls
man
like they they must be more expensive to
[ __ ] maintain than just
going out to a soap land yeah but that's
what i mean that's what i'm thinking
it's like these things are so expensive
you're better off going to like a soap
land you know ten times
this is a shame right right i i get it
it's a bit different but i get it i get
it though like the financially it makes
sense
yeah there's a shame the shame of having
to go to a prostitute or something
basically
i think i'd rather do that than [ __ ]
fly a the shame of having someone look
back at you
as opposed to like looking at lifeless
eyes that they can't judge
hey if other people want to [ __ ] do
it that's fine i don't care
i can't do that man yeah the shame would
be too much for them i had i had a mate
who like couldn't go to any strip clubs
because he was just like
yeah going to a strip club it's just
like looking at porn that could look
back at you man
i've never been to a strip club and they
always just seem weird like i just the
idea of it
and it's sad because everyone always
tells me the food is like normally the
best part of it and
what i would not order food industry
the boys go to a strip club just to have
like a five course delicate meal man
why not i would it's like it's like your
friend is like yo
i know you're [ __ ] great strip club
stakes are [ __ ] born so much
like i can't remember who it was in
america they're like yeah dude the wings
were bomb
and i'm like i'm like yeah in my mind if
any food would be good in the strip club
for some reason at that point does that
mean you've just gone to too many strip
clubs where you go you go there and
there's just like naked girls dancing
you're like no no no no give me the
wings
i would pay for a youtube series where
someone is like very
loudly in like a music blaring he's like
reviewing a strip club
and the wings i would pay good money for
that it's my review bro
yeah like a report of the week in a
strip club like reviewing the wings
he's like can you turn the music down a
little bit yeah
so please out of the way i i fear for
what i don't know i don't want to use
any of these sex toys because i don't
want to i don't want to start liking
them
yeah because i feel like i'm just going
to get more and more extravagant with it
until the maintenance costs are through
the roof all right i'm happy with where
i'm at right now
just just beating my meat just getting
it done my own trusty hand
you know it does the job i don't need
more than that that's that's why i'm
afraid of like
trying something like vr porn you know
what i mean where it's just like this
this is going
what if i like it yeah this is going an
extra mile here this is this
this like yeah exactly like what if i
like it what if i experience something
new from this i don't know i don't want
i don't want to i'm not i'm in a happy
birthday
recently you recently bought a vr
headset i mean i bought it to play
[ __ ] games okay
i want to play the last life index there
is no way there is a part of you that is
like
i gotta try this out there is no way
there isn't a part of
course there is but like so i just don't
like the idea of coming with a headset
on
there's something about that that feels
wrong like i'm wearing a big ass headset
with these controllers and [ __ ] like i
don't wanna [ __ ]
you kidding me i can imagine like the i
can imagine just
like like you climax and like the post
not shame must be on another level right
because she's just a headshot
you've got the controllers and you're
like oh this is this is where my life is
right now ah beat saber okay
i just yeah again like i i feel like i
don't know you just did a video on this
didn't you where you went to illusion
yeah yeah and played the vr porn games
that they made
it's [ __ ] weird like i don't know
i did like a safe for work one because
barely safe if you were in the privacy
of your home could you nut to it
if i tried really hard maybe what do you
mean if you could try really hard like
if i was if i was given like 30 minutes
to myself like maybe
i'm sure i could manage to come to
anything if i had 30 minutes that's what
i'm saying it's like it's it's not the
optimal thing i would use
because it's like i don't know it's like
there's a part it was really fun
to do yeah because it's just so
ridiculous but there's just so much
about it that's just so jank where
you're just like
oh okay i'm supposed to be lying down in
this thing but i'm
also standing up and if i look down i
just look into the guy's neck
i mean it's just a bit weird that's the
thing about vr porn right i mean you
have to be dedicated to this wank
session you know what i mean
there are so many steps you are putting
on just to jack off
you know what if the like the senses get
like that they're like stop working
midway
mid wank finish finish just yeah
i guess so i guess so it's it's it's not
exactly a casual wank is it you know
it's ranked competition it is a [ __ ]
side question like
i guess the thought i guess i thought i
had was
i've watched the least amount of anime
this year and i feel like
a lot of people have been last sorry
last year i've watched the least amount
of anime last year
and i feel like a lot of people in the
anime fandom have right yeah
and i feel like the community now is
evolving
from just being like there's a
difference between now being an anime
fan and a weave and we touched on this
earlier
but i realized this when hanging out
with connor how much of a normal connor
is compared to both me and joey
like how does it feel you're saying how
does it say you're an army
how does it feel for you hanging out
with like people like us i guess
or what do you mean people like
why do you think i'm a normie first of
all okay because you don't care about
anime as much as we do
i care about anime no you care about
anime but there's only you you only go
so deep into the culture right
where you don't really get waifu culture
you don't really get
uh a lot of like [ __ ] you yeah
no comment well like
youtube part of the culture i think it
is yeah i mean it grew out he grew out
of the anime culture right
i mean you know you gotta kind of have a
like an appreciation for anime in order
to watch anime girls streaming
i i mean i guess yeah i don't know i
just i
mean like like how deep how deep do you
say your anime fandom goes
that's a weird question well how could
you frame me maybe a scale or something
that you could
judge me by uh five b ten
one okay again okay okay one is like one
is like
you know i watch attack one time that
might hear academia like just like just
getting started
and 10 is like i look at an anime and i
know exactly who the gengar artist for
this is
[ __ ] that what are you on that scale
where would you put yourself actually
then this
might help me judge like i'd say i would
put myself as a seven or an eight
probably like act it probably would have
been like a
five but now it's probably like a four
yeah three honestly but it's probably
probably gone down to a three yeah you
know recently yeah i mean it has has
like your has
do you feel like you've become less of
an anime fan like more recently
and have you like fallen out of the
culture ever since you moved to japan
i guess i guess because uh um i mean
it's not like you don't watch anime
really you still
i love like the community in general but
uh
i think just when you get so deep into
it it would start like
and the community i just started to like
not enjoy the community when it got to a
point where it's getting really deep and
everyone's like yo name your favorite
key animator and i was like yeah
what who cares i like the show and the
story i don't need to care about that no
i mean
like you know we can argue that gan and
i are probably at that point too but if
someone came up to me and said name your
favorite key animator i'll be like
i think i think there was just a lot of
like at least when i was i don't know if
it's still going on i mean you guys can
tell me but that when i was getting
trying to get really deep into it i
really wanted to learn more about it
it got very like gatekeepy at a point
yeah it definitely did people like that
it's been like that for a while
yeah honestly where i just started to
like not really enjoy it and then i
realized i think i just
i enjoy these shows way more when i'm
just casual i mean i just kind of
learned
i just kind of learned to appreciate it
more and kind of get deeper into it
without
really interacting with the community
around it yeah well i guess for a lot of
people
i think me included when i get into
something the one thing that i
will always do is just like look at the
community for it all right be like right
what's the norms what should i get into
what's everyone saying like the best
thing
because that's a way of like guiding
your like it's like a tailored
experience of like what everyone thinks
is the best
way of enjoying something because i feel
like you don't really follow seasonal
anime anymore right you just kind of
wait to see what
everyone's talking about and what's
worth watching like how did you decide
what anime to watch but i think that's
because
like the seasonal experience of viewing
animes kind of like died almost
like i don't think i don't think so i
don't think people nearly talk about
seasonal anime in a
week-by-week way like they used to i i
disagree i just think it's because last
year was like so dry for seasonal anime
um that there was just
nothing for people to talk it was just a
lot of mid shows last year yeah
i i just feel like now especially with
like netflix coming and releasing the
episodes in like
oh yeah but like everyone is like it's
not you know did you watch the latest
episode of b stars
did you watch b stars no yeah but like
you know that's like one out of every
[ __ ] hundred but i feel like i feel
like everyone asks that now it's not did
you watch the newest episode itself it's
did are you watching i mean i
i i would say like are you watching like
people are still asking are you watching
the newest episode of attack on titan
people just say are you watching attack
on titan are you watching the newest
episode no literally every stream i do
there's always okay
people are like if you watch no it's
like have you watched this anymore
because
on titan is different attack on titan is
like an event not a tackle time like any
seasonal anime no normally i never get
seize the line if you'll ask me no
i get that all the time no one gives a
[ __ ] if i was watching like or i'm on
what is that what's it called a rhymer
all right
what's it called that's it
i'm on yeah
generic feels good anime that's an eight
season you know
like are you watching that no one asked
me [ __ ] about asking that if i'm
watching that [ __ ] right no one asked me
if i watched decadence you know what i
[ __ ] mean like no one gives a [ __ ]
because
there's so many animes that are so mid
now and then
decadence i tried watching right now
there's so many animes that are coming
out that the only ones people
i seem to have that because it used to
be again when there's a lot less anime
as well
that everyone could kind of ask are you
watching these shows are you watching it
weekly
yeah and now it's just so [ __ ] many
and we have so many like good shows but
like we only really
i find in my experience that general
twitter only really asks if you're
watching a show weekly now
or keeps up with the hype if it's a big
event like attack on time right right
right because i feel like what was
missing last year was that [ __ ] big
event because last year we had something
like the demon slayer that demonstrate
episode that really like
but even then i never saw like week by
week plays by demon slayer people
week by week everyone's like yo yo demon
ep demon slayer
17 boys what are we all saying what were
we all saying on twitter you know there
wasn't like any of that it was just
episode 19 was
amazing it gave the birth of my children
jesus christ is reborn like
that's what happened right that was it
like there wasn't anything else other
than like demon slayer
good right yeah that was it i feel like
do you not think that's kind of like
it shifted a little i am i am i seeing
something
i i think i think maybe it's just
shifted just because you've kind of
shifted away from it because i've also
shifted away from it too and i've
definitely noticed like the lack of but
i i think i do feel like that's that's
so many people because i i know so many
people now
who like they say they're anime fans
100 yeah and and they they they all they
do
is read manga watch youtubers and play
gacha games
i mean this photo you know what i mean
that's literally me that was mean 2020.
i never see people talking about episode
three of this it's always chapter this
of this manga because everyone knows
that they're released at this point and
then everyone keeps up with it on
twitter yeah
but i never see it for for anime no one
does anime episode reviews anymore
except for like big shows attack on
titan re zero yeah everyone does manga
chapters things
still they're so popular i mean this is
i genuinely think it shifted i don't
think i'm the weird one here no no i
can't see the truth i think what's
happening i i i i disagree with like no
one does episode
reviews anymore because there's still
like there's still like a big group of
youtubers who still do it oh really you
watch absolute reviews name every
episode of you right now
chibi's probably the only person youtube
will be taken down and chippy will still
be making reviews
i don't know who like come on that
doesn't count man well no that's
literally like
that's the only one that matters in my
opinion i guess i mean it's
i feel like that kind of mirrors
the culture now because i feel like
definitely
being an anime youtuber last year was
[ __ ] hard
um anime content last year was
like from from my perspective anime
content on youtube just didn't do as
well
because no one was watching any anime
but videos around anime culture
like what you guys were doing you guys
[ __ ] you guys [ __ ] killed it last
year
in my opinion yeah and i feel like
that's because nobody nobody
like people care less about individual
shows now and people just more care
about the culture i think the last time
i did
a show or a video on a show that was
like seasonal and ongoing was
[ __ ] promised neverland and that was
like what two years ago
three years ago like banana fish yeah it
was [ __ ] amazing
it was like it was like two three years
ago right and it's like since then it's
just like
every season comes around and i do what
will i be watching and then i look at
the list and i was like
the biggest lie joey needs to change the
title that i lied to you for 20 minutes
what
yeah of course no that that series now
is just a [ __ ] quick easy way of
being like oh let's see what joey thinks
about this
yeah we know he's not gonna watch it but
at least we'll know what he feels about
it
for me seasonal anime has just become
this glorified manga recommendation
system
yeah well if if i find a series like
this
it's so rare because this is what like
shopping is to amazon
i go to the store to go and buy it on
amazon it is right
because because most of the time most of
the time you find it you find an anime
and it's like we talked about this
before where it's it's not
so it's not an adaptation that's amazing
it's a passable adaptation where i'm
just like
i don't get anything more than this from
like watching the anime versus reading
the manga so you just
end up reading the manga yeah it's only
like jujitsu kaisen is like one of the
few
like judician jojo and like some of like
the big shonen ones are one of the few
exceptions where they actually have
budget and money behind this to make
this a
[ __ ] amazing production you know what
i mean but for most for the
most part you have a production that's
just mediocre
it's okay they're just there they're
just there and it's just like i'd rather
just read the manga and get ahead and
speedrun this stuff yeah honestly like
that's how i've kind of found myself too
and also like you know at least
very unique opportunity for me is that
like i can read 90
of the [ __ ] that hasn't come out yet you
know
so it's like why not just get it do you
feel like you would read more manga if
you could actually read it physically or
do you not care probably would
yeah i would although i would annoy me
having [ __ ] tons of manga in my house
and like because i've read it i'm not
really gonna read it again paul jerry
out like
how often do you pick up a manga and
just read it every day that's a [ __ ]
lie
i was ready for that i'm not
joking like everything i have to because
i have so many that have
yet to read yeah but do you never reread
the ones you've read right sometimes i
do
why because i like it otherwise i
wouldn't [ __ ] buy it
yeah if there's a manga i pick up if
there's a new manga i pick maybe if i
speak japanese it'd be a different yeah
if there's a new manga i pick up and i
pick up new manga all the [ __ ] time
because it's like oh i don't know
anything about this this just came out
it might be good
and i buy it and i don't like it i
resell that [ __ ] rewatching media to me
feels like playing you know casual games
on on a you know on a when there's a
ranked playlist it's like why would i
waste my time on this casual game yeah
but you'd never casual game so exactly
yeah
really casual game all the time to me
like when i when i'm when you know what
uh
i'm just building back back in the day
when you'd meet a girl right and you'd
be like oh cool yeah what movie do you
want to watch just like
let's watch white girls my favorite
movie i've watched it like 15 times like
15 times why why would you watch frozen
16 times
did you did you get something the 16th
time that you you know why
i mean i've seen pulp fiction about 30
times okay
movies like that where you misses [ __ ]
tons i get it to go back but there's
you ain't missing any like deep themes
from frozen or white chicks you know
what i mean like come on
i i feel like part of the allure of
re-watching people well
re-watching that re-watching films or
media with people you haven't watched it
before
yeah i understand yeah yeah yeah because
i i feel like the only time i actually
re-watch something now
is when i'm with someone who hasn't
watched the show you're just like you're
just like waiting for their reaction
just like oh yeah that's jumped off
oh the big the big part's coming up
they're on their phone and it's like a
heartbreak it's like [ __ ]
heartbreaking to you
you you want to politely say pay the
[ __ ] attention you scrub
but like you don't want to sound like an
[ __ ] you know that's my [ __ ] pet
peeve dude and
the worst is like the worst is i
remember one time i was showing uh i
forgot what movie it was to aki
and uh and you know she was like really
quiet for like the first hour and i'm
like oh
she must be really paying attention i
look over she's [ __ ] asleep
and i'm just like this is this is this
is so sad
doesn't she make you like watch disney
movies all the time okay to be fair
though i wouldn't watch half the movies
that she shows
unless it but but at least the good
thing is 80 to 90 of the movie she
actually does show me they're actually
pretty good
i think if you ask me would i rather be
you know interrogated in guantanamo bay
or have a girlfriend who's obsessed with
disney or kingdom hearts i think i'd
take one time okay
i think i'd have more chance of staying
sane again i cannot stand
girls who always just want to watch
disney movies it drives me insane
that's like ninety percent of ghosts no
honestly i'm sorry for you joey that's
like that's my nightmare as well
okay i thought i was gonna hate it but
then again i've seen so few disney
movies understandably i'm sure
i'm so glad that girls are moving away
from that and getting into true crime
i can get behind girls wanting to watch
true crime no no no
no if anything i would rather watch
disney movies than true crime no i lost
no
no no i i would have to go with the true
questions you don't understand aki
every morning i wake up to some kind of
police interrogation
wakes up but like is it a rapist today
honey yeah right yeah yeah i'm just like
every time he's just like so why did you
do it so what a good door
yeah it's not just like i don't wanna i
don't wanna wake up to this it's like
criminal psychology channel right that
yeah every girl is watching now jim
can't swim
psychology yeah yeah yeah yeah there's
so many of them there's so many channels
like that and i'm just like i
because i watch the the the gym can't
swim psychology and then i recommend it
was just
it's like the new reaction youtubers
yeah they're all reacting to
interrogations
and i'm like what is happening why are
we reacting to interrogation
like i get it because you watch it and
you feel you almost feel physically
suffocated right
because i i remember watching some of
these videos and you feel like you feel
like a kid again
where you you like you like stole a
cookie and your mom's like
did you steal a cookie and you're just
like oh what do i say what do i say and
it's
it's like that simulator without being
back in that
because they they have like they have
the thing they'll pause the
interrogation be like
this is the backwards suplex uh mental
gymnastic move
and i'm like i love it my mother used to
do that one to me like this is the alter
ego sufficing technique and i'm like
loved it when my dad did that
that's a classic i love that one you
know yeah it's like it's like being back
in school you know
getting told up for detention yeah you
know because the detectives would be
like we have proof and they wouldn't say
the proof and i'm like this is like the
big mind game at school like we know you
did it i'm like yeah [ __ ]
yeah i know and and then they would go
we don't need to show it just know that
we haven't
they're just [ __ ] their pants i'm
just seeing like good cop bad cop in
action and seeing it actually work
and it's just yeah it's it's it's like i
can see how you can fall down that
rabbit hole and it become addictive
like it's interesting don't get me wrong
but every day
every night honestly i could pretty much
every [ __ ] morning
i couldn't do it because it's not
something i want to watch first thing in
the morning i would rather watch a
mediocre documentary over a good movie
that's that's you you have programmed
your brain wrong
i like you you literally have programmed
your brain even
that that just does make sense i just
like real life stuff
way more than like i don't know why i've
somehow gotten into it where i just
really enjoy like stories
but like but like here's the thing
because i've i've thought about this
recently where
i feel like a lot of people now are more
like
will be more willing to watch something
that they don't have to pay a hundred
percent attention to
so if you have like a really high
quality movie or something that you
that you need to like pay attention to
right you're less likely to watch that
than say
[ __ ] trash taste you know [ __ ]
just three people chatting [ __ ] for two
hours that's true or or like a real life
documentary where yeah
not every detail is important you just
get like the basic story around it
that's fine no i don't know i don't know
why i'm like that i just enjoy it i'm
sure there's people out there who the
same like because on netflix i
think all i watch is like documentaries
you've watched every time i meet you
you watch a new documentary i have no
idea where you find a time to do that
i play a lot of them in the background
yeah that's it right but does that
count as watching it well because some
of them are like i said like some of
them are mid
so it's like just put it on the
background and let it do its thing
that's that's one thing i've never
understood is like people who say like
yeah i've seen
like i've watched like you know 500
movies i'm like oh how did you watch it
i just let it play in the background
while i was like cleaning it
does that count as watching the movie
i'm like i'm like typing up while i'm
it's in my peripheral and i'm like
listening to it yeah i don't know i
don't really count that as watching it
what
[ __ ] off that's watching yeah because i
can't concentrate it's it's watching but
you couldn't
do that to something like pulp fiction
that's why i would never treat it like
that yeah exactly with anime and
and i feel like doing that i i've
realized that because i've been doing
that more often with youtube videos as
well and i've
found it harder and harder just to
[ __ ] sit down and watch something
like it's do do you find that like
watching watch unless it's like a super
engaging show like watching any
standard show now it's just it's just 10
times harder because you just want to
you kind of just want to skip to where
the important plot points are
sometimes i mean i've been watching some
pretty good shows recently that i
haven't really had trouble with but
yeah sometimes i have that problem i'm
glad i've never subjected myself to that
because otherwise i'd probably be
feeling the same pain
i don't put something on unless i have
the full intent of putting 100 of my
concentration into it
oh man because i i don't know like i
don't see the point of like
working on something while something
else is playing in the background
because then i'm just going to get
distracted by whatever's playing
i don't know so either way i can't
concentrate on watching the thing
and doing whatever i can't focus without
some noise like i need
yeah i just put music on yeah i mean
music or put something on
yes whatever yeah but like i can't have
anything that's like visual
on you know what i mean like what's the
last thing you put down that you
probably concentrating on them
like was it the boys yeah i watched the
boys was a good tv show that was really
[ __ ] good
that was that was really [ __ ] good
and really i've heard good things about
that yeah yeah i was like i didn't like
didn't really check my phone or anything
i was just watching it the whole time
it was really [ __ ] good that's what
that's the kind of experience i want
whenever i watch something
i i'm kind of because i've been noticing
i've been getting
so distracted recently when watching
stuff that i just
i enjoy it less and i miss the enjoyment
i had when
i guess i was a kid are you one of those
people who like can't be watching
something unless they have like their
phone in their hand
i didn't used to be like that okay and
i've slowly become that person you know
what i mean
and doing that on anime is hard mode man
because
[ __ ] what i'm just gonna read the
song because i gotta read the subtitles
and my [ __ ] god it's like it's like
trying to watch monogatari when you're
eating when you're eating something
right
yeah like it's it's it's so [ __ ]
difficult wait i missed the one second
of dialogue that was important because
the crunching sounds in my ears yeah i
don't really do with anime because anime
again you have to focus yeah yeah yeah
yeah distracted which is why i think i
find it
i don't watch as much as i used to
because it is kind of like i do have to
figure that's why watching anime or
netflix is so much easier because you
watch the dub
and it becomes like same kind of
enjoyment now but watching watching sub
down my watching seasonal anime has just
become that much harder because of that
exact reason
going back to the debate about am i a
real anime fantasy but like
because you mentioned something you said
like uh v tubers whatever anime
manga gacha games why do you feel like
gacha games
is like a big part of being an anime fan
because gotcha is
originally [ __ ] from anime yeah it's
it's
japanese kind of invented it yeah but it
doesn't mean it's it's not that deep in
anime culture
right it's like no it kind of you can be
an anime fan without ever playing a
gacha game
yeah of course yeah but you can't play
but it very rarely play a gotcha game
without being an anime fan yeah exactly
i mean there's plenty of original like
gacha games out there that aren't
anime-based at all yeah but how many
people play those compared to the
anime-based culture games well i mean
is it or how many more how does ginger
impact an anime game
how is how is genji and impact not an
anime yeah well i would consider anime
being like
the actual like manga no anime it's
i'm more talking about like the anime
art style i mean like the interior lanes
the arc knights like they weren't based
off anything
yes and then same with v cheapers right
like i would say
who's watching youtubers who's never
watched anime before you know what i
mean that's that's
a confused dad that's who's watching it
i like
i like the gadget games i mean i really
enjoyed dark knights when i was playing
that i don't really play it anymore
um but like and gention was fine i
didn't like i couldn't skip any [ __ ]
dialogue
i think they added that now though
they've added that i literally rage quit
one of my streams because
there was so much dialogue and it
wouldn't stop like and you would walk
10 seconds to get another dialogue for
two minutes yeah this is taking the piss
this is ridiculous no one can enjoy this
yeah i want to i want to see you play
yuck as a game you'd probably lose your
[ __ ] mind i'd be like what is
happening
what is going on yeah um and like
i don't get it how people can get
excited for every new [ __ ] gotcha
game
i think that's a question you have to
ask me we've also been brainwashed
into being excited for rates that are
higher like than two percent we're like
boys boys it's practically 50 50. that's
practically
one percent once it's above two percent
it's like i
personally guaranteed
they've all memed it so much that
they're actually like proud of it when
it's like two percent they're like
they're practically giving the five
stars away
like that's probably guaranteed
like a lot of the stuff i i just i hate
how games have just completely
normalized like
you know micro transactions to death
yeah like
i enjoyed arc nights it was fun but like
you know i'd spent like 800 bucks on
that game and there was still
submissions i couldn't do and i'm like
yeah how much do i need to spend to be
able to be like do the hardest missions
tell me how much just just turn your
brain off and just enjoy the game and
you're just enjoying
the experience then it [ __ ] is like
you got no [ __ ] resources left
oh you want to pay you want to play a
little money to keep playing do you
because like
i hate that i would say the the only
real gotcha game i'm playing right now
is genshin and my my biggest problem
with genshin has nothing to do with like
the catcher system even though
the paw rays suck ass but i mean i never
get like if if the
if if the if the drop rates are [ __ ]
ass then i don't go into it with the
mentality of
i'm going to get this character i'm
going to get this person when you come
in
with x when you come in with
expectations that's when you lose
yeah okay yeah that's that's that's when
you feel like walking into a casino
being like i'm gonna win the jackpot my
actually biggest problem with genjin
right now
is that when you reach the end game it
really
it it really feels like you reached the
end game because you you you are
like you're [ __ ] squeezing out
content that's just not there
yeah yeah we went out so much yeah and
it's it's become so apparent with
genchin as opposed to other gacha games
because i'm sure we've played enough
gacha games that when you reach that
point right where you you
you you you're open to do the dailies
and you're like i got nothing to [ __ ]
do this is just this is this is just
like
part-time job i'm [ __ ] grinding away
i gotta clock in on my daily i'm just
watching numbers go up
but like it's it's it's less noticeable
when it's a phone game but when it when
it's on gention because i don't know how
[ __ ] people play gentian on the phone
man
how you do how you do storm terror or
the [ __ ] wolf
boss again on your phone that's that's
[ __ ] beyond me yeah but like it feels
so weird when i got to the end game
gentian and i would log on for like an
hour a day on
on the pc and i would just like i'll
just grind and
and i'll do nothing but grind because
i've done all i've gone through all like
the
the actual content of the game and it
really
it really feels like it it's really
apparent
on genshin because it feels like the
first real gacha game that's like
that should be played on console and
feels more like an rpg whereas
if it's a mobile game i mean you just
you can do it whatever whenever you can
do it in your free time
yeah because i mean i definitely felt
like when i was grinding arc nights and
i was over leveled for a lot of things
even though i still couldn't beat some
stages
like the fact that because you would do
it daily because you've been conditioned
to like get your daily rewards man get
them yeah to the point where
anytime any new content ever came out i
[ __ ] steamrolled
it like immediately and i was like well
that was like two hours of fun i waited
three months for that
content update i do feel like a bit like
a pavlov dog pavlov's dog yeah
i mean where it's just like oh good new
content good new content
oh and it's just like you can't like you
can't [ __ ] on these games
and like say oh man yeah it's super
grindy you know
the the microtransactions are a little
bit much whatever and then people are
always
so quick to like defend them and i'm
like just admit that it's [ __ ]
and what they're doing is like you you
get a free game and then you you have to
put up with this [ __ ] and they're like
well i'm free to play i don't give a
[ __ ] if you're free to play
other people are out there spending a
thousand dollars why is it okay if it's
just
you're [ __ ] free to play that's
always the excuse you see this [ __ ] yeah
it drives me insane people like
what do you mean i'm free to play i've
never had any difficulties it's like
well good on you that you have willpower
you know like i mean
that's i mean i'm i'm one of those
people honestly free to play no not free
to play but i'll defend the fact that
you can
play these games being free to play
because all you need is willpower and
you know if shut the shut the [ __ ] up
all you need is the power of friendship
that's all you need
i mean if i wanted to i could be free to
play i just don't want to
i don't know it just feels i i feel bad
for the people who
physically like can't control their
gambling yeah i mean i i i i i should
be playing but they should not be
playing games like this and i feel like
i feel like these games should really
come with a warning tell that to take
time yeah
exactly it should come there should be
like heavy warnings
and games i think to like say hey listen
you can spend a grand
and come out with pngs like what was
that were you looking at guys
so they're just full off okay sorry this
should be like a heavy warning saying
listen you can
spend a grand for like an animation the
png that gets you a little bit of
serotonin like that's it like no money
involved
like gambling totally fair that it's
like well i just it
yeah i it angers me so much how like
you just don't see the value in those
people i mean that's that's just a new
generation right
what would you want to pay for do you
want to pay for more money no i'll pay
for a little bit of serotonin people
don't
like often you never hit people like
defending gambling odds right they're
just like yeah dude
it's what it is gambling's what it is
and you go in there and it's [ __ ] and
yeah if you want to go and waste your
house always
going where you want it yeah but but
gotcha everyone's like oh no actually
like it's everyone's like i guess
because the option there is free to play
yeah but because
there's no free to play play gambling
option right
well actually some sometimes will like
give you free drinks so just turn up get
a free treat let's go
i guess that's the equivalent of free to
play right yeah yeah i have an orange
juice please
no gambling that's that's the equivalent
of like free temple today
yeah and they are generous but i guess
people if you don't have a gambling
addiction you can't understand how it
feels to have a gambling addiction
yeah yeah exactly and i get it why some
people might just want to play a game
don't know that it has like gambling in
it maybe yeah essentially
and then they get like kind of track
tricked into it because they've been
weaned on the game and then
that's that's just modern apps
though because because we've just found
a way to literally hack our brains
like human being like we we like to
think that we're not predictable right
but how how of like five ten years ago
can you imagine like just
like having most of your life have most
of my life now is scrolling down on
something
yes you know what i mean most of my life
when i'm not talking to you guys i'm
scrolling down on some kind of [ __ ]
timeline yeah yeah i guess
it's never ending philosophical stuff
here yeah yeah but back to the point of
gadget
right the other thing that we've done is
that we've done the best thing that we
could
ever want for these companies we've
memed spending money yeah we've cause
every nobody wants to feel bad for
wasting 200
and not getting what they want so what
do you do you go to twitter you tweet
out how you didn't get anything and you
may
pick like the pain pekka whatever it's
called
that is that is a pog champ right there
oh god stop meaning about me being a
boomer for one second listen
we have all like tricked each other into
making gambling like a community event
and like like enjoying it yeah because
because no one wants to lose alone
because we share the pain right
we share we share the pain pick up yeah
we've done what exactly what these
companies [ __ ] wanted us to do yeah
which is
make like the gambling into like a form
of acceptance
like you're not truly you haven't joined
like you haven't joined the gotcha
community unless you [ __ ] gathered
a thousand bucks and haven't got the one
with thick thighs you forget about three
months later [ __ ]
no are you telling me that part of like
the gambling experience like
you go into a casino i remember the last
time i went to casino with you
great time because you got to you
[ __ ] egged on eugene to like lose his
money
and he probably wasn't [ __ ] hilarious
that was funny so you eugene's our
uh friends um so you basically did the
exact same thing yeah
what happened was that i you know at the
time he didn't have a job
and we were telling him you know you
probably shouldn't be spending your
money yes but i i was like you know i
kept playing
i didn't lose much like 100 bucks yeah i
i was planning that much and he wanted
to keep up with me and i was like if you
wanna you can go ahead about i'm not i
don't have to do it i don't know man
that sounds very suggestive to me like
i'm going to gather reverse psychology
it's like i'm going to do a ten port i
mean
you don't have to do it i just i mean
you know i mean
whatever
me going to a casino and being like hey
guys this [ __ ] gamble on blackjack
hard man got blackjack you know it's the
equivalent
i mean it is the equivalent of that i
mean it is i mean like i said gotcha is
a wi-fi because
you know stream gambling is that there's
poker i know yeah there's pokemon
jack can you is that there's pretty
heavy rules around it though yeah
probably but there's not heavy rules
around gacha
no i guess why not why not should that
be should there be
but there honestly should be i think
there should be some regulations i i
feel like
the biggest thing about gacha is that
people should know what they're getting
themselves into
um people should know a lot of things
that's why that's why people should
also have the option to tell casinos hey
can you ban me because i have no
self-control
there's no way to do that with gotcha
and unfortunately unlike this is that is
that an option with casinos
yeah in every country you can do that
you can you can basically so what you're
saying is we need to come up with like
the gasha police you basically need
something
you need something you've been spending
too much money
i am dead seriously there should be
something on the like play store or
something that you can be like listen
i gamble too much can you please not
allow me to spend more than like
100 bucks like a year or something like
set a hard limit that there's no way to
turn off
i i i agree with you because because if
you go to the casinos you form says
please ban me from this casino they will
never let you in ever
like because they have like a database
and a lot of the time if you
uh i think sometimes some courts require
you to do it for certain occasions but
it's very popular and common that people
who gamble too much but they want to get
their life on track
you know because it's it's easy to have
a lapse in like
willpower and you go to the casino yeah
so if 95
of the time you're like i'm never
gambling basically chastity build
themselves right
basically you can say like this is not
good for me i'm gonna fill out a form
i didn't know you could do that yeah
yeah in the uk 100 uh because
gambling is like a huge problem in the
uk for like betting shops and stuff so
yeah they'll they'll do it and you can
basically if it's a chain as well
they'll ban you from every chain
and they'll have to do that but like i
do i do think you're talking about uh
like a vast minority because like most
the people who i've met
who have who are playing gacha games
they've they're not like
no no they're not like us right but for
us it's kind of like
like for me at least you know it's it's
kind of like it kind of revolves around
my job you know what i mean you stream
you stream you do it it gets views right
yeah exactly but like for most people
that
i know that play gacha they haven't
spent like an inordinate amount of money
on it but like i don't think there
should be an ability
to ruin your [ __ ] life for falling
anime girls
because like we know uh techtone he's a
popular uh
gacha game streamer yeah and at one
point he used to play what was it um
summoners he nearly like i think he went
homeless right
he legit went like finance he like i
think he might have
filed bankruptcy something yeah he went
fully broke from gacha games yeah
gosh this should never be a thing that
should never remember him telling me
that like it was like a [ __ ] like
story that should never be a thing for
casinos either right
no but i mean there's more i agree there
should be more regulations about it
there needs to be a gotcha police
because what we need
again with casino it is extremely
heavily regulated
yeah right and you can win money so it
makes sense
that you can't have the risk of winning
money without losing money
right but with gacha games come on for
some people though man like that png is
worth more than one to me
it is it blew my mind that it took like
i'm in serious how many why what's wrong
with you because that's
what happened in your childhood
serotonin because like i've never
cared about anything no no no no no no
until those pngs came off i've never
cared about winning money because like
you know to me money money has value
like oh obviously like
[Music]
you can't you can't put a price on wi-fi
that's serotonin here when you win
like a [ __ ] character that you're
actually emotionally attached to you
know what i mean
because people who win money in casinos
they're not emotionally attached to this
money i doubt that i've done it
very much no no i've i've had friends
who have had
actual you know proper gambling problems
as well and i remember this
my i knew a friend in uh university who
one day
won like 10 000 pounds in a casino
right could have paid off his student
loans could have you know could have
been
like completely debt three and within
within three weeks he had spent
the 10k 10 10 000 pounds gambling on
on gambling mostly right and i asked him
dude you could have [ __ ] invested
this money
you could have used it like more wisely
you could have used it to better your
life why did you
spend it on gambling or why did you
spend it so easily and he said
because i didn't care about it because
he didn't earn it right because because
he
because he had no emotional attachment
to the money because he was just giving
it so
to him it just felt like it is the
equivalent of just someone coming up to
you being like he's 10k yeah
a lot of these you know the serotonin
hit you get from these waifus three
months say you don't give a [ __ ]
well that's not that's like that's your
prerogative dude do you give a [ __ ]
about some of the games that you pulled
for and got that that lovely serotonin
hit like no but i
i i have a nice memory you know what i
mean i have i had a ghost just [ __ ]
like
like ah yes i remember the time in my
pocket i had a good experience playing
like all the gadget games i played
otherwise i wouldn't have played them in
the first place it's like you know going
to
it's like you know small basically the
same as like going to a [ __ ] arcade
or something right and like putting
money into that no
yeah that's different yeah no no it's
different it's like yeah you're only
paying you know maybe a hundred unit at
a time but it's still the same
it's like why is that what's the problem
is that it's you could do 100 yen at a
time and if i wanted to spend
500 bucks which i try to do yeah it
takes like five hours
yeah for a long time if you want to
spend 10 grand on gacha
give yourself 20 minutes 10 grand in 20
minutes you probably could
if you were just buying this the highest
option multiple speed running bankruptcy
let's go baby like you could i'm sure
you know
like like you see the streamers who
spent like 10 grand
and but they're they're making the money
back yeah about all the people who are
doing that who aren't making the money
right
yeah and yeah some people are probably
in the financial position to be able to
do that
yeah but why even give yourself the
chance of like
making that happen to other people who
aren't right like you hear and again you
hear the horror stories of
kids spending their mother's money and
[ __ ] like that like why is this even
able to happen this shouldn't
there should always be a hard limit
built in that shouldn't be able to like
be able to okay let me let me ask you on
the person though yeah let me ask you
this what regulations would you want to
see then
what regulations how did you fix this
problem that you've uh
that's that you've presented when you
download the game
right and there is gacha in it there
should be an immediate question of
what is the maximum you're willing to
spend in like one year and you
physically no matter what you do cannot
go over that like you they will what if
you said zero and then you change your
mind
well that's on you you've already said
that the same as just putting in the
credit card numbers by yourself anyway
yeah you've decided zero you then can't
hurt yourself more and you're stuck with
the thing because you agreed to zero
i think that should be a thing no
because like on on the
on the other side then that means
spending money in in in
essence is also on you right that you
know that that's
that shifts responsibility from just one
place this is the problem
like the problem that people have with i
think when they're talking about like
gambling addicts is that
we don't think of it because we're not
gambling addicts we can't think of it as
why don't you just not spend money bro
that's not that's not how it works yeah
that's not how it like
this is the problem is that i think
people alienate these people and don't
even remotely think
how it is to be in their position right
now i totally understand but at the same
time it's
what i'm trying to say is obviously they
are there are people that are proper
gambling addicts
that have a problem that they you know
physically you know
like cannot control harder time to
control
it's not but how do you how do you
introduce a system where
you know how do you how do you introduce
a system that can regulate
that you know as opposed to you know
other people who
have you know no problem you know having
willpower and
being able to control their spending and
financial decisions i do think that
there should be a hard limit
on monthly amount of money you can spend
on any game i legitimately believe that
i believe i do not think that like
anyone should have
any excuse to spend over like ten
thousand dollars on a video game a month
like that should be just that should be
like a hard limit baked into the game or
app store
or something like that because no
realistically no one needs to spend over
a grand
yeah and if they do if everyone's
playing by the same thing if no one can
spend over
a grand the devs won't make games that
are able to get benefit of spending over
a grand you know what i mean
like i don't understand why there hasn't
been some kind of like hard limit on
video game spending
like that because why would the devs
[ __ ] why would they think it's
like it's the best interest yeah i know
like i i that's
that's probably the best solution i can
like agree on because i i do feel like
there should be a hard limit on how much
you can spend i think there also should
be something again with like how you can
say i want to quit like casinos
because you know gambling addicts
probably aren't gambling at it
24 7. it's probably like a lapse of like
willpower where they're like [ __ ] i need
to gamble some
you know i'm depressed or something i
don't [ __ ] know i don't know how it
works but there should be something
in the system that's like okay i want a
gamble all right and then
you can say that or at one point when
you download the game say i don't want
to gamble you can only change this in
say
seven days of like are you sure so you
say yes i want to gamble all right
come back in seven days if you're sure
you want to gamble we'll let you gamble
right why not something like that
developers
because because most of the money i
better spend is
every everyone's moment of weakness
where they're like you know [ __ ] i'll
spend a hundred bucks come on let's see
what i get come on yeah you know what i
mean
most i mean how often would you spend
100 on the gotcha if i had to ask you
joey come back in seven days tell me you
still want to spend 100 bucks
i just wouldn't bother with playing the
game at that point well you'd play it
free to play
yeah or not or not play it at all yeah i
mean i i i say more more than anything
i'd probably not play it at all
yeah maybe what if you can't spend money
in the game well no if i'm
[ __ ] like if i'm persistently being
asked like are you sure are you sure
you want to do it i'm just like i'm not
even going to [ __ ] bother with her
then that was that intrusive
what do you mean you won't let me spend
my money i'm furious it's like leave me
alone i'll spend it if i want to spend
it it's like the opposite now where
they're like
spend money spend money yo get this pack
get this pack off yeah
and i'm like and i'm in a position where
i'm like i'll get the pack if i feel
like getting the pack
but i'm not going to feel like the same
thing what do you mean you could just
say no to the money thing
yeah you literally just said the same
thing
but you're just being an [ __ ] now
yeah i literally just gave you the
opposite situation where like spend
money spend money and you're like i
don't i'm fine i don't want that yeah
so what's the difference of saying no
what what
i'm going to do like you're just playing
devil's advocate just to piss me off
yeah i love pissing you off
it's my favorite hobby no yeah i mean i
i ca i can ignore my serotonin
there's been way too many cases
obviously our people are going i'm
[ __ ] broke spending that how many
cases do you know
yeah how many do you know you're at all
the [ __ ] time from who from who i bet
if you asked how many people had like
spent a significant amount of their
savings or like i spent too much money
sorry spent an amount of money that
ended up like they regretted
yeah i bet there would be like fifty
percent minimum
can do it right now we can [ __ ] do it
yeah yeah i'm fine
i'm on twitter have you ever spent an
amount of money on a gacha game or a
video game that you ended up severely
ruining be honest be honest yeah
be totally this is a proper scientific
conduct we're doing right now like
we actually want to know like no meme
i'm actually genuinely curious
i love gaming so i'm a gamer gamers rise
up
rising grind and i i i am a casual gamer
i just like enjoying my time playing a
video game
and if i you know if if i want to you
know enjoy my time
pulling for some waifus then that i know
i know that that's on me because i know
that that's what i'm paying for
you know what i mean yeah i i also me as
well i understand that i have
self-control i don't need to do that i
don't regret
any money that i've ever put into gotcha
no from from the beginning
would you ever say that you've fallen
for something that is perhaps like you
know
maybe a little not predatory but close
to it right maybe like a
they keep offering you stuff you know
there's deals constantly look i'm i'm
not gonna lie and say that gacha isn't
just [ __ ] gambling with waifus
because it [ __ ] is okay
it's but like i've never seen i've never
i've never seen the appeal of casinos
because because of the reason that i
said
where you know to me casinos are scary
because you
you pay for the chance to win more money
and that's that's like
that's that's like that that's to me
that's like a risk right
because that's literally just gambling
but to me like gotcha
is i'm paying for an experience i'm i'm
paying because i actually want
this thing that i'm putting money into
you know i i actually want it
and it's it's different where people are
going to meme this and say oh
god doesn't care about getting money and
it's that's not what i'm saying right
i'm saying if i'm if i'm going to get
money there are plenty of
other ways that i would want to get
money i would [ __ ] is the last
gambling's the last gambling's the last
weight i would use to actually get money
i would
i want to work for that [ __ ] but there's
only one way to get wi-fi
i rarely give a [ __ ] about what memes do
right i'm not like that but
i guess because we're in the position
where we all have our own job we're all
old old people compared to the zoomers
out there and the coombers
okay apparently you're the youngest one
but you're the beginner i feel like a
boomerang
when i go on twitter sometimes i feel
like you are the boomer right
so it's it's all hella normalized right
spending
you know 100 bucks on a few pulls right
me and the boy is going to pull a few
wifeys right
you know we're joking about it on
twitter you know where we stream it but
it's not like you know someone goes to a
casino and it's like oh i do a cheeky
like 10 pull on roulette right and then
like
you know everyone's memeing it the
classic
you know bet on red all right because
we're membing the ship right
to like 16 15 year olds who are then
wanting to do it right yeah i mean like
we have like a
like i don't know it feels weird okay
well the what what i would say is okay
like
part of the reason i've been spending
more on like gotcha now is because 2020
has been boring as [ __ ]
or 23 was boring as [ __ ] and i and i
think to myself what up what would i be
what would i have spent that money on
anyway probably going out and getting
pissed like
how much do you spend on a night out
like it depends right yeah it depends
[Music]
let's say uh let's say a standard sesh
in london with the boys right you can
spend
upwards of like 100 200 pounds now what
are you getting up to in london
popping champagne [ __ ] what a drink
when a [ __ ] when one single cocktail
in london
is like a tenner like you you start off
you start off like a weather spoon or
something you know that's that's the
cheap drinks but like as you get further
or further on the
night people easily spend a hundred to
two hundred pounds on one
get more out of that ten minutes of
pulling that catcher than a whole night
with your boys
i mean i would say that no no no no
you're a politician right now god what
is this come on man i'm just answering
the question
i'm just saying like like you you you
are like
yo i'm being attacked right now i need i
need to irish i
i need to [ __ ] defend myself i need i
need to [ __ ] defeat
the speaker but you know you say
you say we've normalized the stuff but
like you are fine
for example spending that much on a
night out because that's what you choose
you know that's what you choose as the
experience and that's what you choose is
okay for the price you know what i mean
so basically what you're saying is a
night out with the boys is the
equivalent to getting your favorite
wifey there's there is tangible stuff
you are buying you're buying drinks
that is stuff that has to be made that
you're going you're transporting
this is all stuff that you know has a
cost for a reason
the gadget is inflated because they know
they can get away with it right they
know they can charge this much for a
pool i mean it's the equivalent of like
going out to a bar
and buying a tanner drink and going home
and pouring yourself that same drink
right
no it's just yeah no it's the same
because like getting of getting a one
getting your favorite waifu on a free
pool
is is the is the pouring your drink at
home no no it's not yes it is
what's the going out then what's that
the [ __ ] temple you pay for
what no that's exactly what it is oh my
god this is
so such low brain like you know dude
okay when you go to a
uh like let's say you go to a bar in
london right you pay i don't know
[ __ ] nine pounds for a cocktail
you're not paying for the ingredients
right you're paying for someone one to
make it you're paying
you're paying for the experience you're
paying for the experience you're paying
for like you know the the glass
the expertly prepared right you're
paying for that yeah
do you have nice cocktail glasses at
home no i'm gonna buy them they're like
[ __ ] 30 quid they have really nice
ones right
everything you get is tailored
experience that's where the price goes
is it a bit of a rip-off yeah kinda yeah
but it's not like to the point where i
feel like i'm being taken advantage of
right with capture games i kind of do
well that's just on you
no i feel like they i think i genuinely
believe that like
gadget games to some extent are like
just taking getting away with as much as
they can right i'm taking advantage of
course of course they're getting courses
i mean i'm i'm not gonna say that
they're not getting away with as much as
they can
i totally believe that yeah there should
be regulations around this stuff
it is that's that's that's not the
argument here that's not the argument
yeah the fact that it took like
multiple governments to get involved
just to make them to show you the odds
is like ridiculous like how long were
people getting [ __ ] over because they
didn't know the percentage was 0.001
oh like a long
yeah but how is that ever acceptable
like that that was okay like casino you
know the odds
right right like even casinos aren't
that scummy they'll let you know
like like this this just blows my mind
and how people constantly defend them
and they're like
is i would i would be more okay with it
if everyone just admitted it's just one
big scam
and we're all just in for it because
it's not it's it's not a scam though
it's it's not a scam
it's like one step away from a scam i
mean what's that one
what is the scam for you then what is it
genuinely because because to me a scam
is like it means that you are getting
what's what's the word i'm looking for
like the users in the dark
we know exactly what we're getting
ourselves into and that's why to me
it is not a scam a scam is like saying
like oh on this banner
the ten poll is a guaranteed six star
well that's not a guarantee
that's obviously that's come in to stop
any more like government regulation
right because if they were trying to get
away with that
lying to the foreign base yeah then that
to me is a scam which i'm sure many of
them were at some point yeah right
now we didn't know we don't know unlike
this i mean come on
the best weapon against that is just
education right it's it's like
no no it's i'm giving you laughs yeah
don't do drugs
no you have a wrinkly brain that's all
it is like i mean i mean the [ __ ] up but
if you want to
if you want me to talk about the like
the realities of it i will talk about
the [ __ ] realities of it and that's
because
i don't want i i i know exactly what i'm
getting into with gacha games and i know
what my limits are
i do think it's it's gotten much better
since they've won you get a guaranteed
and you know you get to see the rates
that's much better yeah that's that's
increased a lot
like i i mean i mean up i mean the [ __ ]
up there i'm like
spending money on on like literally a
[ __ ] 0.6 percent
but that's not me you're right i know
i'm not going to be able to make that
decision no no but even
even if i wasn't you know what i mean i
know that's on the person
not always i think i think sometimes
depending on how
we're going circles kind of but like
depending on how the game is presented
and made
i think sometimes a fault it can be on
the game right
and i hate how you can't even have this
discussion of people like oh you're just
whining bro it's free to play anyway and
it's like it's not that simple
i think it's never that simple i mean i
feel like if i think not opening the
door to that conversation
is irresponsible i mean for me i feel
like the conversation
to me always ends at if if it if it
doesn't feel like you know your type of
game
like i don't feel like you are made for
gadget games and i i
i genuinely believe that because i feel
like someone with your personality
like a true [ __ ] gamer just would
never enjoy gotcha games no i don't i i
hate that i
paying for part of the game yeah i hate
that and i'm i'm completely fine with
that gotcha games the reason i love
gacha games
is because it suits my lifestyle
perfectly it suits
my mentality when it comes to playing
games perfectly he's a true
gamer girl i don't like i'm not saying
that gacha shouldn't exist or anything
like that i totally recognize that it
has its place and it's got its value
i just want like everything to be more
transparent and there'll be
systems in place to stop people going
broke from there because i don't think
anyone should go broke
from [ __ ] like i don't know [ __ ]
arc nights are you kidding me like no no
one should be going broke from [ __ ]
video games why
why was that even an option i mean it's
it shouldn't be an option and that's
that's what we agree on
right right yeah and like i i just it's
like we've totally like been made it
totally memeable and okay to be like ah
he's gone broke
what an [ __ ] like no no we haven't i
mean we haven't memed up people going
broke yeah
if someone's like if someone's like haha
i just spent a hundred
hundred dollars on a gotcha and i pulled
nothing that's that's that's basically
like the same as what you did to [ __ ]
eugene being like
you you just spent you just uh spent a
hundred pounds on a casino and you
didn't yeah also there's nothing
there's nothing on twitter that's not
getting memed up like
you could scroll on twitter being like
lol his dad look like if someone has a
legitimate problem and someone's like
dude i've i've fully regrets you know
spending this much on the gadget then
i'll be like bro i'm you know i i feel
you yeah like sorry yeah you know
you just gotta quit you know what i mean
that's this is this is bad this is bad
yeah
there's nothing else we can say though
in our position there's nothing else you
can say stop doing drugs bro just stop
why do drugs man
like it's not that easy that's again and
a point
no more no there should be regulations
bottom line someone needs to make the
gotcha police a reality
bottom line there should be regulations
whether on how strict they are that's
up for debate between catcher players
and uh pro gamers
apparently pro gamer girls and gotcha
gamer girls
the never ending war i think there
should be like a cool down period
100 that's my that's my closing
statements i'll getcha games
predatory that's the title oh my god no
why not because that's a brilliant title
because then the entire [ __ ]
gotcha game community is just gonna
destroy us well that's
let's see that's the problem is that the
catch-up game is get offended when you
insinuate there could be anything even
predatory about it
why that's that's not what we said i
never why though why why do i do that
like i've seen
the moment you complain about gacha
rates there are like a horde of people
being like
i'm free to play no no because because
we
because because basically from like from
a lot of people's perspective
it sounds like oh you're enjoying this
thing no you're not allowed to enjoy
this thing
you know what i mean it's like why are
you enjoying this it's wrong to enjoy
this thing no no the games are totally
good the games are great again it's a
great game or all chill whatever you
want you want a free play cool you want
to spend money
cool but i just think there should be
there shouldn't be like predatory
systems on anything
to do with video games it's like it's
like having like a [ __ ] fisher price
toy and being like do you wanna like you
wanna you wanna roll for a new new
[ __ ] toy
you wanna ten dollar you know what i
mean like you know we don't put that
[ __ ] in there so you're not the kind of
person
who's like oh there's a new dlc i don't
give a [ __ ] about dlc i don't i
you can be the game as is that's what
i'm playing i'm never gonna you're just
a true gamer
yeah you're just a touring gamer this is
the most vanilla gamer out there i was
like vanilla
hardcore i'd like you to add go and
[ __ ]
go and play a [ __ ] disguised book and
call it a game what is your perfect
gaming experience connor
what is your performance no the [ __ ] off
no league player would ever say that oh
well why do you play so much
well that's a good question joey
addiction there should be a system's in
place
there's some restrictions but league
addiction is a [ __ ] thing don't try
to
tell me that you don't try to tell me
league addiction is not a thing it is a
[ __ ] thing
yeah yeah but it's not like i mean it's
you have to try very hard to ruin your
life
with a league addiction you have to
really be on that path
um but i don't know perfect game for me
i don't know maybe like something like
one of the halo games it was a very
[ __ ] good game perfect game
experience you get a good game maybe
some wait some of them had like dlc
but that's points down for that points
down for that
yeah i don't know are you talking about
like og halo
yeah yeah like hello one two hella
wanted two really [ __ ] good games
just a game that has an experience that
is when it's over
what about like a current game a current
game was hades is probably the best game
i've played recently
all right that's a fantastic example of
a game no dlc no [ __ ]
just play the game you know you get the
story if you want that
i'm not into that yeah that ain't me i
mean by the gameplay
[ __ ] amazing right to me to me to me
like i 90
of the games i ever play i don't finish
i i
i don't know why such a i could weak
minds no no exactly
i get to a point no i'm just
i don't play final fantasy i don't i
don't play yakuza i don't play any of
those long games right also that's
longest game i played like [ __ ] blue
dragon or something [ __ ]
like i have to be like properly invested
in this stuff and i'm the type of guy
who
you know i get really into a game and
then i hit about
like the 20-hour mark and then i still
have a quarter of the story left or a
quarter of the gameplay left
and i i feel like i've gotten everything
out of that game that i need to do
and then i just stop playing you know
what i mean like part of a lot a big
reason why i
you know even with gacha games is that
if there's not that reason for me to
keep playing or if there's not that if
i'm not getting something new out of it
then i just drop it what do you mean
it's just a [ __ ] daily quest every
day
well sometimes i like the story
sometimes i you know sometimes it is
you know sometimes i'm sometimes you
want to get that grind for that
character the moment you said
story he just checked out yeah he's
i could see his brain just blowing power
down i kind of father my people want to
grind
like why people put themselves through
that it's it's torture
i mean it's it's kind of like just that
mindless task right yeah it's just
something to do you feel like you're
accomplished or something [ __ ] are you
telling me that league isn't a grind
after a point it's a [ __ ] grind
it's just it's just a grind with more
complicated controls
you know what i mean yes it is yes
there's a loss and there's a like a win
and a loss
have different outcomes grinds there's
only one outcome you just win
you just you do the thing that you're
meant to do and then you've already
depends how you grind
yeah but it's like all right i've got my
spreadsheet out it's going to take eight
years of grinding of killing these balls
what what
is what what is that how you do every
jrpg player what would you do we have a
[ __ ] spreadsheet no but
in your mind it's like i'm gonna do this
mindless task five times to get this
what is the end goal of league there is
no end goal it's like self-improvement
in mechanics
exactly checkmate so that's exactly it
right because that's my problem with
competitive games i
you know you i every time i get to do a
competitive game whether it be league
overwatch um [ __ ] valor or whatever
is like the the
golden period is the first time you're
learning the game right and you start
getting good at the game anything
you start learning the systems and then
you start the ranks you start the ranks
playing you start climbing that's when
the game is fun
when you feel like what you've learned
has had a tangible effect right
but everyone everyone will hit that wall
everyone will hit that wall where you
climb as hard as you can
unless you're a [ __ ] faker or
something even what you've i mean you've
won like the world tournament that's
cause that's
that is basically the only end goal
there can be in any competitive game to
be the best in the world right yeah and
so everyone
will reach a point where it becomes a
grind because there's there's no way
that you can overcome that wall without
grinding your way to overcome that wall
yeah
and then that's a self-improvement and
then you reach and then after you do
that
you reach another wall and another wall
after that but it's constantly like
improving a skill but in like jlpgs and
you know gadget games often
it requires no skill to do the grinding
in fact it requires the opposite
but what i'm saying is you feel like
you're because the whole you're working
towards a goal
you're like you talk about
self-improvement well you're working
towards the goal you're you're
gaining something to us gacha games is
just that i mean like
we've we've not just gotcha games but
like i'm pretty sure like any mmo right
when you're grinding
you just feel like you're making
progress towards something you just
you're just
less that's like fun to people just like
having the thing like the super easy
thing just play out you're like not
engaged at all
just because you're going towards
something yeah you know sometimes i
don't want to feel shitty when i've
you know played five league games and
lost five in a row and i'm just like i
play games to have fun not to engage
it's it's it's it's just like you're
just activating like the
[ __ ] neurons you don't need to worry
about it i just like being lost i just
like being challenged constantly like i
want something that like is challenging
you
always like and the moment you grind how
do you not get tired
what do you mean i don't know why i like
being challenged constantly i want you
do you not feel like competitive games
get to get to grind
get get to a grind after a point do you
not feel like
used to a point where i feel like okay i
genuinely think unless i put x amount of
effort in i'm not gonna improve at this
game yeah right
i normally just quit at that point
because i'm like all right i feel like
i've gotten all the challenge i can out
of this game
in a reasonable amount of time right i'm
gonna find something else yeah and
that's exactly the same for me when i
when it reached the point where i
reached that grind half of these gadget
games have auto play
so what are you doing sorry what are you
doing are you just going
to you're working yeah i mean that's
that's why that's why you know what
the only times i'm okay with autoplay is
when it's on a mobile
because they're [ __ ] staring at my
phone while it's auto playing the entire
time i'm doing other [ __ ]
yeah yeah but because i've been out with
you and you're auto playing on the thing
and you gotta like keep track of it a
little bit make sure it's all going well
you're like okay
for like two seconds and then doing
other things you also can't use your
phone in that time because you're
doing the mission so you can't reply i'm
sorry i have other things to do then
look at my phone
i have emails to reply to joey i have
you know messages i got to reply to you
man you know it's busy life but
you know yeah i don't know i also like
not [ __ ] my battery which is like
really annoying on the gadget games
when i was playing arc night my i had to
carry a [ __ ] spare charger with me
everywhere
my battery was [ __ ] dying for me when
gadget games stopped getting fun
is the moment i start thinking about
optimization because when i start
thinking about optimization i'm just
like okay
now now i'm just now that i'm just like
that is the challenge for me
because once i figure out how i can
optimize this game maximized right
then it's not fun but i figured
out immediately because all the shit's
online and everyone tells you how to do
it so once
you've you've seen this yeah so you
basically like just willingly is like i
just figured out a way to make this game
not working
there is nothing about what are you auto
playing when you're [ __ ] [ __ ]
when you're opening up a spreadsheet and
you know [ __ ] actually
thinking about how to optimize this and
optimize that that's when it stops
getting fun i just like the experience
of just doing like a very like a very
simple activity i don't need to worry
about it and i just feel like i'm
gaining something and it's not i'm not
going to say that hey this is the peak
of all
entertainment this is why i play video i
guess you know what i mean
it's just a nice little thing i cannot
understand like my brain cannot wrap
around
the thought of just just progressing
maybe i'm the monkey brain in this thing
because to me the idea of progressing to
a goal without actually doing anything
seems like the dumbest thing ever like
why
how is it a goal if you're not
progressing because [ __ ] life is
stressful enough bro
what do you mean it's like i get rid of
life is already a challenge we don't i
don't want another
challenge on the side yeah i de-stress
by getting like challenged to do stuff
out outside of like like you're [ __ ]
weird because there's no pressure if i
lose in a ranked game i'll give a [ __ ]
it's my i'm not gonna get my [ __ ]
mortgage taken away from me like
it's nothing like that right with a
mindset like that i'm surprised you're
not a speedrunner
no no because that's the exact same
mentality i feel no no no no that's
psychotic
because that's like i want the same
experience again with a minute
difference that that to me
like blows my mind like that's exactly
what i'm hearing right now no no i
because when i get done with the
challenge i'm done i'm on with another
game
right like these speed runners will
spend like two months to get a one
second optimization right and i'm like
that's
all about optimization yeah and other
things but not my
like complete my fun like my fun is
learning something and getting better at
it
like i will optimize i mean i mean
wouldn't you say that that is speed
runners because they're learning
a game yeah that's awesome almost an
obsessive amount though
i think like i get it this because i've
i got into like speed running like
carpet at one point right that's quite
fun because i was seeing good
improvements
yeah but the moment it became not fun is
when i would do a
40-minute run and i i was just like i
don't really know what to do now i
didn't really see much
to improve and then i would look online
and i'd be like okay i guess i can i can
do this but
yeah sure the mechanical aspect of
trying to get better at like a certain
thing was better but
it was a challenge yeah but it was it
was it was not
when you play against other players
there is an always in constant direct
challenge facing you and every second
there is constant
thought decisions you have to make to
outplay and every new game is a new
experience
yeah right there's a lot of things that
are the same but with a speedrun i think
the problem i have with it
is that it's always like we follow the
formula and then we try and improve on
the formula
little by little right which is not kind
of fun because if you're doing like
people do like three hour games at speed
runs it's like
they might do like a two second
optimization here and then redo
everything the same way
right that sounds like insanity to me
you're not changing anything there's no
variation
you're just changing one detail
constantly trying to improve it and sure
i can understand why that's fun to
someone
but for me i can't do that and i i just
can't get invested in that that's just
not what i do
so what do you get invested in then like
again self-improvement
self-improvement and the fact what is
your definition
seeing how well i can apply the skill on
the fly to things like how well i can
learn it and adapt to situations
is what's fun to me i like losing
because that means i can get better
for me i play video games because i just
like escapism like you know
that that is my escapism yeah to me
video games i like i i do this
i do that enough in my real life you
know what i mean if if
probably that's probably why i [ __ ]
watch so many easter go around i'm just
i'm just realizing this now man
but no like i came to another world but
yeah it's it's just like i i want to do
something where
you know sometimes with the actual games
you know there's no way you could lose
at a gas game unless you're [ __ ]
spending money but like
like in terms of like the grindy and the
progress there's no way to lose against
it
so you just don't like losing hmm you
don't like losing who does like losing
i like losing you're [ __ ] the
experience no it's not
every fighting game player is obsessed
with losing i swear yeah that's why
they're all psychotic that's like some
[ __ ] martial arts mantra
oh and
they they couldn't drift on mario kart
right i thought this is a very basic
mechanic this is not that hard
and i was like you should just try it
like without the baby mode on
because i feel like the baby mode just
all you're then doing is holding a
right like without bait because the fun
part about mario kart right is drifting
right i think and nailing drifts you
know and
use you know playing the game i like
drifting in mario kart okay i'm going to
say that for like 90th time
so you like drifting and mario i love
drifting you say that as if it's an
unpopular opinion
i was playing with someone the other day
right and i
i i was like i was like they couldn't
beat you after
a hot day i drift in mario kart
they couldn't beat me in mario kart
right and i'm like yeah it's cause
you're not [ __ ] drifting you're never
gonna beat me if you're not drifting
and they were like oh okay i guess i'll
try and they tried it once right they
tried to they tried without baby mode on
they kept falling off the edge and
they're like no i don't like mario kart
now it's not fun
yeah i'm like what did you expect you
were just going to be amazing right away
no you got to put some effort in start
learning how to drift you dumb [ __ ]
try it the fact that you've gotten that
competitive over [ __ ]
mario kart that just shows how much like
you're meant it just shows what you're
meant to have
it drives me insane when people try
something like that right
that is not that okay we're not talking
about i'm not like just get good at
starcraft bro i'm not asking that i'm
like
press one button on mario kart when you
come to the corner that's all i'm asking
right that's what i'm trying to explain
to you yeah
people who like throw a fit and like i
don't want to play anymore it's not fun
now i failed this one mechanic and i
don't care to learn it
like that drives me insane i can imagine
the dad you're gonna be
yeah you mean you can't drift in america
you're you're disappointed
you're you are nice to me i i do not
have like people would be like wow
connor's that guy with like because
to me fighting game combos are absurd
like the amount of combos and inputs
you've
put in right because you're too much
like there is such a steep learning
curve right
again there will be a fighting game
community be up in arms yeah yeah i'll
be like
okay connor like that that's the
drifting in mario kart is such a low
barrier of entry in terms of
intense mechanics yeah like for you no
no
is it really do you think it is i know
some people who just
no matter what game it is some people
just don't
their brains just don't operate right
when it comes to games even even a
simple mechanic like drifting
they're just like i don't know i think
to to me it's like if they had never
wanted a drift it's fine
but they wanted to drift and wanted to
learn and then it was difficult and they
gave up immediately and that that's what
annoyed me
is that they immediately gave up well i
mean isn't that this is how do you get
how did you get anything done
but isn't that the equivalent of you
playing tekken and being like i want to
do this combo and you try and you're
like i don't like it
no i was trying the combo and i'd be
[ __ ] [ __ ] at it i got my ass clowned
on yeah then i realized
i'm just not getting better at this game
right that's the exact same
thing no not the first i would try
multiple sessions to get good at it it's
it's just
it's just the same thing with a with a
different difficulty curve
you know what i mean it's just like it's
just it's just a different way this is
what i have one life versus i have three
lives
this is why i said i prefaced right in
the start i'm like it's not like i'm
asking you to get good at starcraft or
anything intense i'm not asking you to
learn
intense mechanics whilst pacing it is
mario kart drift explain and yeah but
you have to understand
some people for some people that is
intense and that's how is that
are you telling your grandma can [ __ ]
figure out mario kart straight away
if you're my age mario kart drifting
should not be an intense mechanic i i
like
i i think you like it's like early onset
dementia if that is a problem for you
honestly
that's some big claims though everyone
ever i do not expect my grandma
to even know how to get like just click
the [ __ ] menu on the nintendo switch
right i'm not expecting her to do that
right very extremely basic mechanics
right
like okay but this is the okay again
this is not my problem that they can't
do it they said they gave up
right away the first failure of the
first track they're like i'm done
maybe because they don't want a [ __ ]
challenging experience in a video game
maybe they just wanna
if you're like you're like the navy
seals dad
i despised out those people you're
becoming one
i would never expect someone to be good
at any video game are you
are you trying to say that you're
playing mario kart for fun
no no no it's all about the challenge
it's about the show
okay how about you i would never claim
to be i want to be good at fighting
games and then i'll try and give up
right
if i want to actually learn something
i'm gonna i'm gonna do it i'm gonna
throw a hissy fit and give up when i'm
not good at it
that's just how you operate so you have
to realize not everyone is an epic gamer
girl
some people just don't see games that
way and you just have to accept that
i just think it was annoying no i get it
i get like that's annoying to me as well
but i'm not gonna get like pissed off at
them i'm just like well that's just
that's just how you play no
that that just means probably it just
ain't in the game
it's just it's just it's just saying
maybe they just don't like playing games
genuinely off the top of my head i can't
think of an easier mechanic to learn
than the mario kart drift
can you name it is your mechanic go
right now
probably i'm accelerating in mario kart
actually no it's automatic now joey
oh there you go actually yeah there's an
option there's an option it's all
automatic by default so
you don't have to do that turning in
mario kart but the album baby mode it's
automatic that's what i'm saying
there is literally the game play that's
what i'm saying there's a reason why
they added those mechanics
because for some people because they
want it's just too much but then that's
what i'm saying
they just want that monkey brain neuron
activation
to use mario kart might be a baby game
but for some people it's the equivalent
of playing something
i said it was a baby game i'm just
saying right what happened to us is that
what you're saying they don't know they
were complaining that i was winning
right you're never gonna win if you
don't drift right so my problem was that
they complained that i'm winning
i told them how i was winning i
explained to them this is how you can do
it
and how easy of a mechanic it is to
learn like you can learn it in one
sitting very comfortably
like most people would if they actually
just tried but they just gave up
son just just start winning son just
start winning just get good
just get good son no why are you winning
son why are you winning why aren't you
winning
i would it would never get to that point
my son would be discerned before
i would be like why haven't you won
already son that's one i'm kidding
why am i the [ __ ] for thinking that's
like just like i don't know you should
maybe just put
like i don't know complaining about
competitive mario kart
no no no i'm not kidding about that i'm
complaining about the part that they
gave up
immediately and we're like i can't do it
i hate when people do that like i just
can't
i hate it too but i'm not like [ __ ]
like losing my [ __ ] over
i don't know i don't give a [ __ ] about
it [ __ ] mario kart
if they don't want to win in mario kart
that's all right [ __ ] [ __ ] america
i don't give a sh i can't give a [ __ ]
if someone gives up in america but
they're like a little hissy fit and i'm
like that's your problem man stop giving
up on [ __ ] in life this is why you get
nothing done
that's why you're not in the navy seals
bro like my dad that's why you never
excelled at anything son because you
gave up the first time like if you're
getting if you're getting a pissy over
someone like losing in mario kart or
something throwing a history in america
no i meant
something more
they were getting pissed off and then it
kind of pissed me off that they were
getting pissed off about it because they
didn't put any effort in
well yeah but when you try to get me
like with a gotcha moment on fighting
games and it's completely not related at
all
it is related
basically the like them giving up on not
being able to learn drift in america
is exactly the same situation as you not
being able to learn the
difficulty curve in the fighting game
because it's completely different thing
right if that was
my own choosing right and i went through
that or like someone pushed me on it
they're like you should start learning
combos right i could totally understand
if i was pushing it on them that they
wouldn't want to do it i wouldn't want
to be good at it
because i mean that's i'm putting on
them they never wanted to do it in the
first place but you were pushing them to
drift
no i never said that you did no they
said how was i winning i said drifting
and they were like oh i want to do that
i literally said that stop putting words
in my [ __ ] mouth jerry you [ __ ]
what i'm saying is like if i cho if i
was pushed into doing it totally
understand why
you would then give up basically just
like you just say people who give up i
hate people who give up right away
i hate it dude what's the right amount
before someone gives up
when it becomes acceptable yeah i mean
you can tell if you're like good at
something when someone just isn't
getting the hang of it and they aren't
going to get a hanger before you know
what i mean
like if you've been doing something for
a long time you can just tell they're
struggling
right right but like most people like a
lot of like not
most people there's a fair amount of
people out there who could are perfectly
capable of doing something who just give
up immediately because they failed the
first time
yeah probably were you guys with ranked
games i imagine
no i mean i don't give up immediately i
just get bored
sure i don't i just paid your money i
don't even like that i don't even i
don't even start because i know i'm
gonna hate it
yeah because you because i don't even
try because you have a hissy fit when
you lose at games
yeah and i don't want to have a hissy
fit when i'm losing your game like why
that's not why i'm like
why do you get a hissy fit when you lose
the game because
when does it ever feel like there's
someone named me a moment where i'm like
oh man i lost like no one says that
i don't give a [ __ ] when i lose it again
i'm like right well fair enough i got
outplayed you know man what is it
that does that feel good to you
sometimes if i know where like i could
have gone [ __ ] wrong with you
no i think i heard i think it is a like
it is a healthier mindset to be of
i don't mind losing so i can improve i'm
not i'm not that that is the complete
[ __ ] opposite of the league
experience my
my friend the league experience is [ __ ]
me i lost was it my fault or was it my
teammate's fault i have literally no
[ __ ] clue
no i did ask no in league when it was
completely my fault i mean there are
some games you know it is 100
there are some games when you're it's
like the 50 50 game
and then your teammate is just caught
out 1v5
while like you're all doing baron or
something and then you just [ __ ] lose
the game thanks for that and it's
that that feels horrible that it feels
awful that doesn't feel great but then
you know you can leave that game be like
right i could have set that up better i
could have done things better that make
that w more secured right
i don't look at games that deep man i
just do it to [ __ ] escape well no
it's
i don't look at it deep what happens is
that i enjoy games and then i look into
now when we're talking about it i'm
thinking okay why do i enjoy the games
that way and that's why i'm talking
about it now jay i'm not
sitting there my window's still like why
do i enjoy suffering on league oh
i don't know no that is the question
that we're posting why do you enjoy
that all league players right now i'm
league free man
i'm playing the game of like i'm league
free man
i've played a rank game of league in
like two months man three months
i went to leagues anonymous and i just i
just [ __ ] said it man i was like yeah
i'm fully free congratulations everybody
claps
basically i enjoy league the most when i
don't care about
winning or losing like that's that's
literally that's literally my enjoyment
of those types of competitive games
and uh i think joey's just a little
gamer [ __ ] a little little crybaby boy
uh and that's where we're gonna end it
today
[Music]
i'm sorry i enjoy winning again
i'm sorry i just enjoyed i'm gonna be
one of those old people like these kids
these days they don't know how to lose
they're gonna learn how to lose it all
how do they expect to win at life if
they can't even
win in a video game that's what i'm
saying man
how can you expect to win a lifeguard
when you can't even take a loss in
[ __ ]
smash bros joey i don't know man i'm
winning so far
it's funny wait until that loss comes
along joey you'll be in you won't be
able to suffer as a human being you'll
better work
oh no i i apologize that i'm giving off
a very nice human
[ __ ] people people take enough l's in
life
life throws enough yeah at [ __ ]
people that some people would just want
an escape from that you know what i mean
some people weren't honest some people
some people just want an escape to a
secure dog what do you think comment
section this is uh
this is why did you have to say that now
we have to hear it
now this is going to be a [ __ ] show in
the comments what do you think comment
section watch
whichever you're a child gamer or a
little baby boy joke which philosophy do
you
uh do [ __ ] sideways what i like about
philosophy there's no correct answer
except my answer do you want to be the
navy seals dad like
connor who just can't stand his son
losing at
anything or do you want to be a normal
father let us know in the comments
you just want to be a normal loving
father
who loves their children for who they
are let us know
i gave up on most the sport
anyway thank you to these lovely patrons
on screen right now look at them they
are just sick of them
look at look at these they're beautiful
people they're all epic
this guy does ranked sex that's for sure
but hey if you'd like to join us on the
patreon make sure to go to patreon.com
also follow us on twitter
subreddit and if you're an audio only
listener then follow us on spotify all
that good stuff
yeah all right yeah i've been chat gamer
boy i'm very tall [ __ ] boys
bye-bye spy episode trash taste that's a
thing
[Music]
you